herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
schulz vertuschung aufklärung
fragezeichen
vor einem jahr wurde ein gutachten zu
den missbrauchsfällen im kölner
erzbistum erstellt doch es wurde unter
dem tisch gehalten es wurde
zurückgehalten
in etwa 20 minuten soll ein neues ein
zweites gutachten im erzbistum köln
veröffentlicht werden wir werden live
dabei sein und auch hören was kardinal
werke der erzbischof von köln dazu sagen
wird in einer kurzen stellungnahme
auf diesen tag haben viele gewartet vor
allem viele katholiken und vor allem
viele betroffene die das opfer geworden
sind von sexuellen übergriffen von
missbrauch durch männer der katholischen
kirche wir werden mit einem solchen
betroffenen nachher sprechen patrick
bauer
er hat das ganze erlebt zunächst aber
wollen wir im studio über das ganze
sprechen mit unserem kirchenmann unserem
experten für die katholische kirche
jürgen erbacher schönen morgen morgen
jürgen ist das heute ein brisanter tag
wenn dieses zweite gutachten
veröffentlicht hat ja das ist ein sehr
präsenter tag für die katholische kirche
in deutschland nicht nur für das
erzbistum köln
denn die zurückhaltung dieses ersten
gutachtens seit nun einem jahr hat doch
massiv zweifel aufkommen lassen wieder
bei vielen menschen ob die katholische
kirche wirklich es ernst meint bei der
aufarbeitung und bei der aufklärung des
missbrauchsskandals auch wenn immer
viele andere bischöfe betont haben
wir machen doch viel wir haben eigene
gutachten wir haben andere gutachten die
zweifel sind gewachsen in diesem jahr
und damit ist natürlich ganz
entscheidend was wird heute wirklich
veröffentlicht was werden wir dann
nachher wirklich wissen werden wir ganz
klar namen genannt bekommen
verantwortliche dann das ist ja das was
vor allen dingen auch die betroffenen
interessiert in der ersten phase der
missbrauchs aufarbeitung ging es
natürlich ganz stark um deren eigene
erfahrung aber in einer zweiten phase
will man jetzt wissen wer sind die
verantwortlichen wer hat priester täter
immer wieder versetzt
wieso hat es so lange gedauert oder
wieso dauert es teilweise auch so lang
dass einzelne fälle dann aufgearbeitet
werden und das erwartet man jetzt
erwarten wir alle heute von diesem
gutachten jetzt im blick auf das
erzbistum köln
aber das hat natürlich auswirkungen weit
darüber hinaus jetzt ist in den letzten
wochen viel über das verhalten von
kardinal woelki gesprochen worden
diskutiert werden worden über das erste
zurückgehaltene gutachten
wir wollen aber zunächst einmal auch auf
das eigentliche schauen nicht nur die
vertuschung den umgang mit der
aufklärung sondern über den eigentlichen
anlass von gutachten und diskussionen
nämlich die sexuellen übergriffe den
missbrauch von kindern und jugendlichen
durch männer der katholischen kirche und
die frage warum ist es möglich gewesen
die taten der täter zu vertuschen
aufdecken und aufarbeiten so das
versprechen des erzbistums köln
doch der missbrauchsskandal ist
mittlerweile ein aufarbeitung skandal
geworden
es geht um 300 opfer und 200
beschuldigte und das seit 1975 eine
renommierte münchner anwaltskanzlei
sollte untersuchen und berichten
vor einem jahr war das gutachten fertig
seit einem jahr hält es der kölner
erzbischof woelki unter verschluss
rechtliche gründe methodische fehler so
die begründung des bistums dass auch die
moralische bewertung durch die anwälte
kritisiert ein zweites gutachten wird
den auftrag gegeben der schaden für die
katholische kirche
der schaden für das bis zum köln immens
vertuschungsvorwürfe kirchenaustritte in
rekordhöhe und kritik an woelki auch aus
den eigenen reihen
er weiß dass ich in dieser sache anderer
meinung bin dass ich der meinung bin man
hätte das gutachten veröffentlichen und
die juristische diskussion öffentlich
führen können
auch wilke räumt fehler ein hat dabei
aber offenbar weniger die
missbrauchsopfer im blick was sie an der
kritik darüber
und insbesondere auch an der kritik an
meiner person ertragen mussten
für all das bitte ich sie um verzeihung
kann das neue gutachten zur versöhnung
beitragen bei den gläubigen aber vor
allem bei den opfern
die voraussetzungen sind denkbar
schlecht es gibt viele viele fragen
viele fragen drängen sich auf auch wenn
eben in wenigen minuten ein zweites
neues gutachten aufklärung bringen soll
wenn sie fragen haben im ganzen
zusammenhang zur diskussion dann einfach
her damit wir versuchen gemeinsam sie so
gut wie möglich zu beantworten darüber
zu diskutieren
jürgen wir haben gehört im dezember hat
kardinal woelki ein gutachten in auftrag
gegeben der kanzlei münchen den auftrag
gegebenen gutachten zu erstellen
aufzuklären et cetera das gutachten
vorgelegt worden aber sogar eine
pressekonferenz anberaumt worden nach
dem motto jetzt wird s veröffentlicht
kurz vorher der rückzieher
nein das habe mängel gegeben und es
wurde zurückgehalten das riecht doch für
jeden automatisch danach dass in diesem
ersten gutachten wirklich exklusive
aussagen war das muss in der tat auch so
gewesen sein denn es sind dann wohl im
unmittelbaren vorfeld der
veröffentlichung dieses ersten
gutachtens einige der personen die
öffentlich gemacht werden sollten
an den erzbischof herangetreten und
haben gesagt achtung wenn dieses
gutachten veröffentlicht wird in dieser
art und weise
dann könnte das große probleme geben und
das war nachher das was was die das
erzbistum köln dann auch dazu bewogen
hat dieses gutachten nicht zu
veröffentlichen das ist eine ganz
schwierige situation weil der kölner
kardinal sagt erkenne bisher dieses
gutachten nicht im detail
die beschuldigten die genannt werden
sollten die wurden natürlich von dieser
ersten anwaltskanzlei auch befragt im
vorfeld der veröffentlichung des
gutachtens und von daher wussten die ok
ich bin unter umständen hier genannt und
mein name wird veröffentlicht und dann
hat das erzbistum köln gesagt ohne den
inhalt genau zu kennen
wir lassen das mal prüfen noch
experten ob das denn wirklich so ok ist
so wie dort namen genannt werden sollen
und das ergebnis so wurde es dann
kommuniziert nach außen war das ist
alles nicht juristisch sauber wenn die
namen in dieser form genannt werden und
deshalb entweder muss die erste kanzlei
nachbessern oder es muss irgendwas
anderes passiert aber irgendwann stellt
man sich die frage also noch wenige
minuten dann gehört das neue das zweite
gutachten auf den tisch gelegt es wird
auf den tisch gelegt dazu stellt man
sich jetzt unmittelbar die frage werden
denn in diesem gutachten daneben namen
genannt also mitarbeiter erwarten ich
gehe fest davon aus mitarbeiter der
kanzlei die jetzt das zweite gutachten
erstellt haben haben vor wenigen tagen
erklärt es gibt eine unterscheidung wenn
personen sich schuldig gemacht haben die
ein sag ich mal
die wie ein erzbischof die sozusagen da
wo ein interesse der öffentlichkeit
besteht dann auch die entsprechenden
namen zu erfahren diese namen werden
genannt werden
aber wenn es zu sagen interne
mitarbeiter des erzbistums sind
irgendein personalsachbearbeiter dann
ist es schwierig einen solchen namen in
einem solchen gutachten zu nennen von
daher werden wir namen hören vermutlich
heute aber wir werden auch nicht alle
namen bekommen derer die in irgendeiner
form an einer verschleppung vertuschung
mitgearbeitet haben weil es da
juristisch eine unterscheidung gibt und
diese unterscheidung so hört man soll
dem ersten gutachten nicht gemacht
worden seien und das sei eben rechtlich
bedenklich gewesen jetzt mal ganz kurz
die frage was haben denn die anwälte das
ist ja eine renommierte
rechtsanwaltskanzlei aus münchen wsw was
haben die denn gesagt als ihr gutachten
einfach unter den tisch gehalten worden
ist da diese nach wie vor davon
überzeugt dass ihr gutachten
rechtssicher ist dass man es
veröffentlichen könnte man hat dort in
der kanzlei auch überlegt in den letzten
monaten immer wieder ob sie es nicht auf
eigene verantwortung veröffentlichen das
ist bisher nicht geschehen
ich möchte es auch nicht ausschließen
dass das noch passiert es wird ja sag
ich mal einer teil öffentlichkeit
zugänglich sein dieses neue gutachten ab
donnerstag nächster woche hat das
erzbistum köln angekündigt kann man
einsicht nehmen das ist juristisch auch
ein unterschied ob man das jetzt ins
internet stellt und damit alles
öffentlich ist oder ob man ein
nicht gewährt das heißt interessierte
journalisten wissenschaftler auch
betroffene können am nächsten donnerstag
im erzbistum köln in einem raum da
sollen dann 20 exemplare des neuen
gutachtens das heute vorgestellt wird
und das ist gutachtens vom letzten jahr
auf einem tisch liegen und dann kann man
sich die beiden gutachten anschauen und
sich ein urteil bilden
ob denn das erste wirklich wirklich so
rechtlich unsauber gearbeitet war dass
es diesen ganzen ja dieses diese diese
ganze diskussion des letzten jahres dann
auch gerechtfertigt hat also du dort ist
damit schon an das wird mega spannend
wenn es jetzt dieses neue zweite
gutachten gibt zu vergleichen mit dem
ersten etc
meine uhr sagt mir sind präzise zehn
minuten noch bis 10 uhr dann soll es
losgehen mit der pressekonferenz und wir
sehen in unserem trio bereits dass die
leitung nach köln steht das ist der raum
wo die pressekonferenz stattfinden wird
die journalistin bereiten sich auch
schon vor ich war ziehen die schärfe
aber es dauert noch zehn minuten bis
diese pressekonferenz offiziell beginnt
erst mit der vorstellung des gutachtens
danach dann ein statement von erzbischof
kardinal woelki jemand der gespannt mit
klopfendem herzen auf diesen tag
gewartet hat der dort in köln live die
pressekonferenz mit verfolgen wird ist
patrick bauer
wir sind jetzt mit ihm verbunden kurz
und knapp vor der pressekonferenz bist
du ihn eigentlich jetzt mal sehen und
können
schönen guten morgen sagen direkt live
nach köln lieber herr bauer schink und
morgen einen wunderschönen guten morgen
jetzt muss ich kurz einfach erzählen
patrick bauer ist nämlich sprecher des
betroffenen beirats in köln gewesen ist
aber aus protest zurückgetreten und
wirft kardinal woelki vor dass die
missbrauchsopfer erneut missbraucht
worden sind ist einer von vielen die bis
heute darunter leiden was ihnen in der
vergangenheit passiert angetan worden
ist und der gehört zu den menschen die
für gerechtigkeit und veränderung in der
katholischen kirche kämpfen
jetzt wollten wir ein kurzes porträt
sehen was das zusammenfasst patrick
bauer war zehn jahre alt als er das
erste mal sexuell missbraucht wurde
täter war ein priester am katholischen
internat in bad godesberg jahrelang
vergriff er sich ein bauer bis heute
leitet diese an den folgen des
machtmissbrauchs ich wurde
instrumentalisiert als sexobjekt für
jemanden der seine liste befriedigen
wollte das erlebte blieb tief in ihm
vergraben erst 2010 mit dem bundesweiten
missbrauchsskandals machte bauer sein
fall öffentlich gemeinsam mit anderen
opfern kämpft er seitdem für die
aufklärung der missbrauchsfälle im
erzbistum köln als sprecher des
betroffenen beirats trat er im streit
allerdings zurück das vertrauen zu
kardinal woelki sei stark beschädigt
sagt bauer
und auch vom heutigen tag erwartet er
sich nicht viel aber es ist jahre her
dass sie sexuell von einem priester
missbraucht worden sind aber was macht
das heute noch mit ihm am ende des tages
sind immer noch die schlafstörungen die
ich habe ich wache nachts auf und ich
denke jemand steht neben meinem bett
ich krieg nachts keine luft mehr weil
ich denke mein mund ist voll
ich habe nach wie vor internet ihren
depressionen immer wieder und das hört
nicht auf also da kann hilft auch nicht
eine therapie damit muss ich lernen zu
leben sie sind jetzt 51 das heißt es
sind schon viele viele jahre her also
dann irgendwie den rücken runter wenn
ich mir überlege dass das sie ja
wirklich ja nicht ein paar jahre als
kind als jugendlicher betrifft sondern
bis heute ja der einzige vorteil ist
dass ich jetzt gelernt habe und weiß
warum ich diese schlafprobleme habe ich
heute weiß warum ich 2007 einen
kompletten nervlichen zusammenbruch
hatte depressiv wurde und in reha musste
das ist der einzige vorteil tatsächlich
ich habe endlich eine ahnung davon was
mir passiert ist woher das ganze kommt
es wer trotzdem nicht auf
was sind denn im grunde genommen seit
der kindheit seitdem sie da missbraucht
worden sind was sind denn ihre quälenden
fragen ja letztendlich die frage die
immer wieder auftaucht auch heute noch
ist warum also jeder betroffene fragt
sich ja welchen anteil hatte ich an dem
geschehen
und selbst wenn ihnen therapeuten und
andere leute immer wieder sagen du hast
keine schuld daran du bist einfach nur
missbraucht wurden
bleibt diese quälende frage habe ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht war ich selbst
teilschuld an diesem ganzen system und
das lässt einen nicht los ich versuche
mir das immer wieder selbst zu sagen du
hast keine schuld du hast dich nicht
dran beteiligt sondern du bist einfach
nur hineingezogen wurden total passen
aber dann fragt man sich wiederum warum
hast du dich damals nicht gewährt warum
hast du dich niemandem anvertraut und
das zeigt das system des missbrauchs in
dem priester pater so überhöht wurden
dass man sich einfach nicht getraut hat
der gedanke war immer noch doch kein ja
wenn wir bei dem thema eben schuld sind
fehler wollen wir einfach mal in einen
o-ton ein statement reinhören
das kardinal woelki abgegeben hat zu dem
thema fehler habe ich ganz sicher auch
im rahmen der aufarbeitung der
missbrauchsfälle gehen sowie dem damit
verbundenen krisen-management gemacht
sicher habe ich hier auch schuld auf
mich geladen
das alles tut mir von herzen leid
wenn sie das hören herr bauer was geht
ihnen da durch den kopf können sie sagen
ja das ist aufrichtig und das hilft mir
nein
das eine ist immer wenn wenn ich höre
ich habe schuld auf mich geladen ich
habe fehler gemacht mir hätte es
geholfen wenn er deutlich die fehler
auch benannt hätte ja also ich kann auch
sagen ich habe fehler gemacht hilft nur
keinem nein er hätte sagen müssen ich
habe die betroffenen instrumentalisiert
ich habe einen falschen weg gewählt
ich hätte die betroffenen früher
informieren müssen
ich hätte auf augenhöhe kommunizieren
müssen und nicht jetzt rum schwan mit
ich habe schuld auf mich geladen
das ist der gleiche mist entschuldigung
so wenn ich das so sage als 2018 die mhg
studie veröffentlicht worden ist und
kardinal marx vor die presse getreten
ist uns gesagt hat ich schäme mich
das hilft doch keine menschen wir müssen
konkrete fehler benennen und wenn das
nicht getan wird wird es niemals eine
befriedung der betroffenen geben jetzt
gibt es ja in ich gucke auf die uhr vier
minuten das neue gutachten was erwarten
sie sich denn von diesem zweiten
gutachten könnte das tatsächlich eine
wende bringen wo sie sagen dann kann ich
meinen frieden finden was erwarten sie
und was denken sie also ich erwarte
heute nahmen
ich erwarte fakten und ich erwarte
systemische fehler des des systems
kirche also wenn wir heute nicht namen
und fakten geliefert bekommen dann
können wir das gutachten gleich in die
tonne kloppen also ich will heute wissen
wer war als personalverantwortlicher
dafür verantwortlich dass ein priester
der missbrauch begangen hat einfach nur
versetzt wurde
wer war dafür verantwortlich dass
betroffene sich nicht äußern konnten wer
war dafür verantwortlich dass ein
betroffener von seinem täter nachher
gesagt wurde
du hast dich ja noch nicht gewährt also
wir müssen endlich klar haben wer steckt
hinter dem system wer hat dafür gesorgt
dass missbrauch innerhalb der
katholischen kirche überhaupt
stattfinden konnte
und solange das nicht geklärt ist wird
es keine befriedung für die betroffenen
ich will jetzt herr bauer bei ihnen sehr
oft das wort system kirche also sie
möchten wenn ich das höre eben etwas
grundsätzliches ändern
ist das denn würden sie denn den
rücktritt von kardinal woelki fordern
oder sagen sie nein das ist gar nicht
das was ich möchte das ist gar nicht das
grundlegende nein ob der erzbischof von
köln von seinem amt zurücktritt oder
nicht ist mir relativ simpel
verzeihen sie mir bitte eine deutliche
sprache heute aber ich bin auch am ende
meiner geduld langsam
der erzbischof kardinal wickie muss
nicht zurücktreten
es sei denn er hat das gefühl er hat das
vertrauen der menschen verloren dann
wenn der einzige weg zurück zu treten
aber das ist nicht meine forderung
meine forderung ist dass das system
kirche sich verändert dass wir macht
inseln abschaffen dass wir das
machtgefälle innerhalb der katholischen
kirche verändern das ist nicht mehr in
einem was will ich mehr innerhalb der
kirche in einem absolutistischen system
leben sondern dass wir tatsächlich in
einem system leben wo wir uns
gegenseitig kontrollieren und
gegenseitig respektieren auf augenhöhe
hin zu einem vielleicht auch tatsächlich
mal demokratischen system in dem jeder
seinen platz finden kann und nicht
aufgrund von geschlecht oder aufgrund
von sexueller neigungen ausgeschlossen
ist
er brauche vielen dank bis hierhin sie
eilen jetzt in den saal der
pressekonferenz werden das ganze live
verfolgen das schöne ist wir werden dann
nachher nach der pressekonferenz mit
ihnen noch mal sprechen
und insofern an alle user kann ich nur
sagen wir werden dann intensiv mit ihnen
auch noch reden und die fragen mit ihnen
diskutieren bis hierhin schon mal ganz
herzlichen dank herr jürgen wir schauen
ein bisschen gemeinsam auf die
pressekonferenz wir sehen da ist der
saal da stehen schon einige aber sie hat
noch nicht begonnen
wir sehen die rednerpulte das heißt es
werden mehrere leute dort seien
vielleicht erklärst du jürgen ganz
einfach wie wird die pressekonferenz
ablaufen wird der kardinal zuerst
sprechen der gutachter das erste wort
hat der gutachter also nach einer kurzen
begrüßung durch den pressesprecher des
erzbistums wird der gutachter professor
gehrke zunächst das gutachten vorstellen
zusammen mit einer seiner
mitarbeiterinnen aus der kanzlei
die werden erst mal sagen was sie
herausgefunden haben danach gibt es
frage möglichkeiten für die
journalistinnen und journalisten
dann wird das gutachten übergeben das
kardinal woelki nach eigenen angaben
bisher eben noch nicht kennt die
staatsanwaltschaft köln
interessanterweise kennt es schon denn
herr professor berger hat gestern gesagt
er hat die das gutachten bereits an die
staatsanwaltschaft übergeben von daher
sage ich mal ist jetzt da gar nicht die
frage was macht jetzt kardinal werke in
dieser richtung damit sondern da ist
schon etwas passiert wenn es übergeben
ist dann wird kardinal woelki ein kurzes
statement abgeben fragen sind heute
nicht möglich an den kardinal ein
vertreter des betroffenen beirats wird
noch sprechen und dann ziehen sich
professor gehrke zusammen mit kardinal
und betroffenen zurück und dann können
die erstmal einsicht nehmen die
betroffenen die öffentlichkeit muss dann
noch warten auch wir werden noch warten
müssen wir haben nur die infos die
professor gehrke in der pk und es gibt
und ab 13 uhr irgendwann beim am
nachmittag soll das gutachten vorliegen
man konnte hier gerade schon mal eine
eine gedruckte ausgabe sehen im raum der
pressekonferenz
ich gehe mal davon aus das wäre zu rund
500 seiten umfassendes wird von daher
auch eine weile dauern bis wirklich
alles dann auch erfasst ist bei diesem
gutachten jetzt begrüßt der
pressesprecher oliver schillings erst
einmal die anwesende presse und wird
kurz das prozedere erklären was jürgen
jetzt schon kompetent vorweg gemacht hat
wir hören sofort rein wenn er der
pressesprecher das wort gibt an den
kölner strafrechtler prof
gerke denn der wird das gutachten was er
selbst verfasst hat vorstellen und da
wollen wir natürlich kein wort verpassen
jedes wort hören ganz kurz jürgen ist es
für dich überraschend wenn jetzt keine
fragen zugelassen sind beim kardinal
nach zu seinem statement also einerseits
ist es so wenn er gleich reagieren soll
auf inhalte des gutachtens erkennt das
bisher nicht also zu details könnte er
sich nicht äußern allerdings ist hört er
natürlich genauso wie wir auch was
professor gehrke sagt und da wäre es
natürlich würde ich sagen gerade auch
nach den ganzen
diskussionen des letzten jahres wenn
sich auch der kardinal hier den fragen
der journalistinnen und journalisten
stellen würde
er hat entschieden das nicht zu tun
sondern erstmal das gutachten mit seinen
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern
auszuwerten und er wird sich anfang
nächster woche dann in einer eigenen
pressekonferenz äußern und dann auch
schon konkret konzept die ersten
konsequenzen verkünden die er aus dem
gutachten das er dann heute nachmittag
auch selber lesen wird ziehen wird man
könnte jetzt natürlich gehalt sein zu
sagen verständlich du sagst das wusste
ich auch nicht dass das gutachten wohl
500 seiten umfasst und bis man die
durchgearbeitet hat das dauert natürlich
aber du hast gleichzeitig ja auch gesagt
der staatsanwaltschaft liegt das
gutachten schon vor da hat gerke bereits
mitgeteilt dass er der
staatsanwaltschaft dass vorgelegt hat
damit sie reagieren kann an einem
heutigen tag könnte man sich fragen
warum der kardinal das gutachten was er
in auftrag gegeben hat nicht vor einem
solchen tag die 500 seiten zum lesen
vielleicht bekommt ja das stellen wir
auch fest bei anderen gutachten die
bistümer in auftrag gegeben haben die
bischöfe sagen wir wollen dann nichts
vorab bekommen damit nicht irgendwie
wieder der eindruck entsteht wir wollen
dann auf der zielgeraden noch schnell
irgendwelche dinge verändern oder wollen
irgendwie plötzlich sagen was doch
wieder ab deshalb ist es eigentlich bei
fast allen missbrauchs gutachten die wir
jetzt in den letzten monaten auch in
anderen bistümern aachen limburg berlin
erlebt haben die bischöfe und die
kirchen verantworten verantwortlichen
erfahren in dem moment in dem das
gutachten der öffentlichkeit vorgestellt
wird auch was drin ist um hier gar
keinen sag ich mal geschmäckle aufkommen
zu lassen hier wurde noch auf der
zielgeraden etwas verändert also du
kennst das gutachten auch noch nicht wir
werden also alle gemeinsam mit ihnen
jetzt gleich informationen das
vorstellen des gutachtens des juristen
des strafrechtlers professor björn
gercke verfolgen uns auch notizen machen
dann werden fragen gestellt werden
können und ich glaube jetzt geht es los
und dann gehen wir über zu epic
wir wurden am 26
oktober vom erzbistum köln mit der
erstellung eines gutachtens zu der frage
beauftragt
ob es im umgang mit fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs minderjähriger und
schutzbefohlener im zeitraum von 1975
bis 2018 zu fehlern gekommen ist und wer
hierfür die verantwortung trägt
unser auftrag ist identisch erst
wortgleich mit dem auftrag den die
ursprünglich hierfür vorgesehene kanzlei
aus münchen hatte bereits der
hintergrund und der genaue zeitliche
ablauf der gutachten beauftragung war
schon gegenstand vielfältiger
berichterstattung auch dass eine der
vielen besonderheiten in dieser causa
vom gutachten auftrag nicht erfasst
waren prüfung und bewertung der
unmittelbaren miss post im fokus unseres
auftrags steht vielmehr die prüfung und
rechtliche bewertung des kirchlichen
umgangs mit denen im
untersuchungszeitraum im erzbistum
eingegangenen verdachtsmeldung anhand
der uns überlassenen unterlagen nicht
eigenständig ermittelt werden konnte ob
die im erzbistum eingegangen
verdachtsmeldung inhaltlich zu treffen
waren sich also die darin geschilderten
geschehnisse tatsächlich so abgespielt
haben
ebenso wenig konnte ermittelt werden ob
es pflichtverletzungen umgang mit
missbrauchsfällen gab für die sich aus
den akten keine anhaltspunkte
es ist auch es ist ein juristisches
gutachten wir sind juristen wieder der
münchner kollege dr basteln als
fachanwalt für bank und
kapitalmarktrecht noch wir als
fachanwälte für strafrecht sind
kriminologen oder soziologen wir sind
kein historiker und wirst insbesondere
auch keine theologen all diese disziplin
vielleicht auch noch mehr können und
sollten aus unserer sicht an der
aufarbeitung von missbrauch in der
kirche beteiligt werden wir selbst sehen
unser gutachten soweit ausdrücklich nur
als einen teil der aufarbeitung unser
gutachten umfasst als reiner gutachten
tags also ohne anlagen über 800 seiten
wir haben zur besseren vergleichbarkeit
die gleiche schriftgröße und den
gleichen zeilenabstand wie die münchner
kollegen gewählt die in ihrem gutachten
auf knapp 350 seiten kommen es ist das
erste veröffentlichte gutachten eines
deutschen erzbistums mit konkret
öffentlich benannten pflichtverletzungen
konkreter namentlich benannte personen
in dieser reichweite und es ist
ungeschützt und so wundert es uns doch
ein wenig dass man sich für den
schlitten den umgang mit der
aufarbeitung der verantwortlichen gerade
das erzbistum köln zur zielscheibe nimmt
nun gut wie sind wir vorgegangen
grundlage des gutachtens sind diverse
schriftliche unterlagen insbesondere
akten und protokolle darunter 236
sogenannte intervention akten
personalakten soweit erforderlich und
fallbezogen unzählige sitzungsunterlagen
und protokolle unterlagen und akten der
kanzlei aus münchen die diese im rahmen
ihrer begutachtung erstellten diverse
schriftsätze und stellungnahmen
teilweise auch gutachten von befragten
und ihren rechtsanwälten weitere
wesentliche grundlage waren diverse
interviews und befragung wir haben zehn
noch lebende personen bei denen aus
unserer sicht nach aktenstudium
pflichtverletzungen in betracht kam
befragt darüber hinaus wurden weitere
personen da wo es für den gutachten
auftrag erforderlich war
unter rein informatorischen
gesichtspunkten befragt nicht befragt
wurden betroffene unmittelbare
missbrauchs täter beziehungsweise
beschuldigte und sonstige externe
personen sicherlich verfügen diese in
vielen einzelfällen über weitere
aus denen sich möglicherweise auf
pflichtverletzungen ergeben könnten
hierbei ist aber zum einen zu
berücksichtigen dass viele zeitzeugen
bereits verstorben sind so dass eine
einbeziehung der aussagen einzelner noch
leben da unser gesamt gutachten ergebnis
empirisch verfällt städte zum anderen
handelt es sich hierbei um eine vom
akteninhalt losgelöste
ermittlungstätigkeit die nicht von
unserem gutachten auftrag erfasst war
vielleicht das gegenstand eines weiteren
gutachtens die zu befragenden personen
wurden alle vorab schriftlich
kontaktiert und ihn eine teilnahme an
der befragung freigestellt wir hatten ja
auch kein druckmittel im wurde ferner
die hinzuziehung eines anwalts zur
wahrung ihrer eigenen interessen
freigestellt das gehört zum guten ton
dazu verantwortungsträgern hinsichtlich
derer wir in den akten mögliche
pflichtverletzungen im umgang mit
einzelnen missbrauchsfällen erkennen
konnten wurde das zu erörtern de
aktenmaterial vorab mit ausreichend
zeitlichen vorlauf zur vorbereitung zur
verfügung gestellt das waren im
einzelfall bis zu 5000 seiten von denen
von uns kontaktierten personen erklärten
sich mit ausnahme einer person sämtliche
verantwortungsträger zu einem gespräch
beziehungsweise einer stellungnahme
bereit
das möchte ich an dieser stelle auch
einmal hervorheben denn das ist nicht
alltäglich
eine weitere person war aufgrund einer
erkrankung nicht in der lage umfassende
ausführung zu den vorgängen zu machen in
diesem fall gab der hinzugezogene
rechtsanwalt eine kurze schriftliche
stellungnahme ab die persönlichen
beziehungsweise mit blick auf die
pandemie situation teilweise per
video-konferenz durchgeführten befragung
erfolgten zum teil unter hinzuziehung
von rechtsanwälten oder sonstigen
beistands personen im vorfeld wurde viel
methode geredet wie sind wir also
methodisch vorgegangen
seit dem jahr 2010 ist in deutschland
eine intensive beschäftigung mit dem
problem des sexuellen missbrauchs in der
katholischen kirche zu beobachten
seitdem wurden verschiedene untersuchung
mit dem ziel der aufarbeitung
durchgeführt zu den bekanntesten zählt
die mrg studie
bisher hat sich aber in deutschland noch
keine einheitliche methodik zum vorgehen
bei der aufarbeitung des sexuellen
missbrauchs etabliert
die einzelnen untersuchung weisen völlig
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen und
zielsetzungen auf auch bei den studien
mit überwiegend juristischem hintergrund
es keine standardisierte
herangehensweise zu erkennen
sie alle sind auf grund der verwertung
bzw einbeziehung unterschiedlicher
datensätze und quellen nicht miteinander
vergleichbar
die gutachten sind teils öffentlich wie
etwa zuletzt dasjenige des bistums
aachen
sie können also ihrer methodik und
wissenschaftlichen tiefe auch
miteinander verglichen werden heute ab
13 uhr dann auch mit unserem eigenen
gutachten
wir standen vor der herausforderung eine
eigene methode bei der bearbeitung der
fälle zu entwickeln
wir haben uns letztlich für eine
kombination aus empirischer und
einzelfallbezogene auswertung
entschieden
dadurch soll zum einen ein
gesamtüberblick über das phänomen des
sexuellen missbrauchs an minderjährigen
schutzbefohlenen im erzbistum köln und
zum anderen eine vorstellung davon
vermittelt werden in welcher konkreten
und individuellen formen einzelne
menschen davon betroffen waren
da jeder fall besonderheiten aufweist
und sich die fälle in art und schwere
des missbrauchs art und intensität der
behandlung des vorfalls sowie
hinsichtlich ihrer komplexität stark
voneinander unterscheiden sagen wir uns
nicht in der lage ein querschnitt aller
fälle zu erstellen oder gar
exemplarische fälle auszuwählen
vielmehr haben wir entschieden alle
fälle in kurzform anonymisiert
darzustellen um jedem einzelnen
betroffenen und sein leidvollen
erfahrung gerecht zu werden
wir haben zudem alle fälle einer
innerlichen vorprüfung dahingehend
unterzogen ob und welche fehler in der
fall behandlung von den verantwortlichen
gemacht wurden
die fälle die eindeutiges fehlverhalten
erkennen ließen führten wir sodann einer
umfassenden analyse zu in der diese
verhaltensweisen konkreten
verantwortlichen zugeordnet wurden zum
zwecke einer strukturierten und
nachvollziehbaren fallbearbeitung haben
wir fünf aufeinander folgende fragen
formuliert die als leitfaden bei der bei
der erstellung des gutachtens dienten
erster welchem umfang gab es fälle
sexuellen missbrauchs im erzbistums erst
bis zum köln zwischen 1975 und 2008
10 zweiter wurden die missbrauchsfälle
von den verantwortlichen und zwar
gemessen an den zum zeitpunkt ihrer
bearbeitung geltenden rechtsnormen
adäquat behandelt drittens wurden die
missbrauchsfälle von den
verantwortlichen gemessen am kirchlichen
selbstverständnis adäquat behandelt
viertens lag der fehlerhaften behandlung
von missbrauchsfällen erkennbar die
absicht zugrunde die vorgänge zu
vertuschen
und fünftens hat die fehlerhafte
behandlung von missbrauchsfällen
systemische gründe
ziel unseres gutachtens war und ist es
eine antwort auf jede dieser fragen zu
geben
bei der wahl der methodik und der
durchführung der untersuchung hatten wir
bestimmte einschränkungen zu
berücksichtigen
zum einen ist zu betonen dass wir jetzt
juristen mit der aufarbeitung beauftragt
wurden es war uns dementsprechend nur
möglich ein juristisches gutachten zu
erstellen
anders als andere untersuchung war vom
auftraggeber also vom erzbistums kein
interdisziplinäre ansatz gewählt worden
das mag man gutheißen oder nicht wir
waren jedenfalls an unseren auftrag
gebunden
es fiel damit nicht in unseren
kompetenzbereich überlegung aus sicht
eines historikers psychologen oder
soziologen anzustellen
gleichwohl erlangten die im zuge der
befassung mit der materie
selbstverständlich in dieser hinsicht
bestimmte erkenntnisse derartige
beobachtungen haben wir aber rein
deskriptiv in unser gutachten
aufgenommen es steht einem gutachter
schließlich schon aus fachlicher
methodischer sicht schlicht nicht zu
außerhalb seines kompetenzbereichs
bewertung vorzunehmen
weiterhin ist darauf hinzuweisen und
dass es fundamental für das verständnis
unserer tätigkeit und dieses gutachtens
dass wir mit dem aktenbestand in der
form arbeiten mussten wir vom
auftraggeber also vom märz bistum zur
verfügung gestellt worden war
das erzbistum die aktuelle spitze hat
insoweit eine vollständigkeitserklärung
abgegeben wonach uns der gesamte
aktenbestand mit bezug zu sexuellem
missbrauch an minderjährigen aus dem
untersuchungszeitraum zur verfügung
gestellt wurde ohne dass durch aktuelle
verantwortungsträger zuvor akten oder
aktenteile entfernt worden wären
dies schließt es nicht aus
dass die gegenständlichen akten die
ihnen zugrundeliegenden tatsächlichen
lebensvorgänge nicht richtig
beziehungsweise nicht vollständig
abbilden etwa weil die akten ob nun
bewusst oder unbewusst nicht nach den
regeln der kunst geführt wurden
diese unsicherheit vermochten wir nicht
zu beseitigen das sind schlicht nicht
möglich war die geschehnisse der
vergangenheit lückenlos zu
rekonstruieren
dies hätte auch den gutachterlichen
auftrag nicht entsprochen überdies haben
wir im rahmen der befragung erfahren
müssen dass in unserem
untersuchungszeitraum also 1975 bis 2018
mindestens zweimal aktenvernichtung 'nen
vorgenommen wurden wie sie das
kanonische recht aber auch vorschreibt
wir haben jedoch alle uns möglichen
anstrengungen unternommen um durch
nachfragen bei verschiedenen stellen des
erzbistums die entstehungsgeschichte der
akten selbst nachzuvollziehen und
dadurch einschätzen zu können inwieweit
der jeweilige akteninhalt mit dem
tatsächlichen geschehen in einklang
steht eine prüfung von verantwortlichen
fand in bezug auf die inhaber folgende
ämter beziehungsweise posten im
untersuchungszeitraum statt
erzbischof generalvikar offizial leiter
hauptabteilung seelsorge personal und
justitia beziehungsweise justiziarin
während erzbischof und generalvikar die
führungsebene des erzbistums
repräsentieren sind die übrigen
genannten wo das was wir in der
wirtschaft mittleres management
bezeichnet würden fehler in der
behandlung von missbrauchsfällen auf
einer darunter liegenden hierarchie
ebene wurden von uns zwar benannt aber
eben nicht einer bestimmten person
zugeordnet weil der erstellung des
gutachtens wurden wir durch externe
experten unterstützt für die
beantwortung kirchenrechtlicher fragen
standen uns herr professor doktor doktor
helmut pre der heute per videoschaltung
zugeschaltet ist so wie herr doktor
stephan korter zur verfügung den ich
hier persönlich sehr herzlich begrüßen
möchte der professor primus ich nicht
viel sagen sie werden seien
wikipedia-eintrag entnehmen dass er wohl
zu den koryphäen des kirchenrechts im
deutschsprachigen raum gehört
insbesondere an der schnittstelle
zwischen rechtswissenschaft und
theologie der einer der wenigen ist wie
beides studiert und den beiden
wissenschaften promoviert haben
herr dr korter ist anwalt für
kirchenrecht und seit vielen jahren
ausgewiesener kenner der materie und hat
eine studie des erzbistums münchen
freising
im jahr 2010 mitgewirkt mit einer
gewissen verwunderung habe ich heute
morgen gelesen dass ihm jetzt zur last
gelegt wird dass er auch des missbrauchs
beschuldigte priester vertreten hat ich
glaube kein mensch würde jemals auf die
idee kommen dass ein anwalt keine
unternehmen mehr vertreten darf weil er
in der vergangenheit mal ein
arbeitnehmer oder ein vorstand wegen
einer untreue zum nachteil eines anderen
unternehmens vertreten hat dann könnten
wir unter anderen strafrechts kanzleien
sofort die tore schließen
beide experten wurden von uns laufend
während der begutachtung hinzugezogen
ihn lag überdies das gesamt gutachten zu
einer abschließenden bewertung aus
kirchen rechtlicher sicht vor wir haben
das gutachten also nicht nur mit den
beiden experten verprobt sondern diese
aktiv mit in die gutachtenerstellung
einbezogen
durch eine norm e-mail-austausch diverse
telefonate und mit blick auf die
pandemie situation per video call lieber
herr professor pre die bei doktor korter
dafür vielen dank noch mal an dieser
stelle
gleichwohl ist es ein juristisches
gutachten deswegen zeichnen sich nur die
anbieter unserer kanzlei hierfür auch
verantwortlich ausgangslage unserer
begutachtung waren also die akten und
dazu gibt es einiges zu bemerken dem uns
zur verfügung gestellten aktenmaterial
befanden sich in zahlreichen fällen zu
den jeweiligen beschuldigten
beziehungsweise auch zu betroffenen
mehrere einzel akten die unterschiedlich
benannt waren
sie trugen die bezeichnung sonder akte
intervention sagte akte hauptabteilung
seelsorge personal oder akte offizialat
inhaltlich wurden in allen akten
gleichermaßen vorwürfe sexuellen
missbrauchs bzw sexualisierter gewalt
behandelt
die unterschiedlichen bezeichnungen
rühren letztlich daher dass die
jeweiligen akten zu unterschiedlichen
zeitpunkten von unterschiedlichen
akteuren zu unterschiedlichen zwecken
angelegt wurden
der begriff intervention sektor entstand
erst als die interventionsstelle ihre
arbeit aufnahmen und selbst neue akten
anlegte bei dem auch in den medien
kursierenden begriff gift akte handelt
es sich um einen informellen begriff der
jene akten bezeichnet die aus der
personalakte ausgegliedert und als
sonderteil geführt werden thematisch
gehören zu den gift akten grundsätzlich
erst einmal alle akten
mit aus katholischer sicht brisanten
inhalt wie verstöße gegen die
priesterliche lebensform sucht und
alkoholprobleme homosexualität etc
gestatten sind grundsätzlich im
geheimarchiv zu lagern
im erzbistum köln galt und gilt in bezug
auf das geheimarchiv insoweit eine
besonderheit als die verfügungsgewalt
hierüber beim generalvikar und nicht je
nach dem kanonischen recht eigentlich
vorgesehen beim diözesan bischof nicht
jedenfalls erster schuss doktor meister
führte nach angaben des erzbistums
zusätzlich einen separaten aktenordner
mit dem schönen titel brüder im nebel in
dem er geheimhaltungs bedürftige
unterlagen aufbewahrt
wir haben erhebliche mängel im hinblick
auf die organisation des aktenbestand
sowie der aktenführung im erzbistum
festgestellt wir haben bei einigen akten
den eindruck gewonnen dass akten
bestandteile fehlten weil die
verfahrensführung nicht nachvollziehbar
war beziehungsweise sich für einzelne
zeitabschnitte keine dokumentation fand
wo eine solche aufgrund der sonstigen
dokumentation zu erwarten gewesen wäre
im laufe der begutachtung wurden
mehrfach unterlagen nachgereicht dies
entweder auf nachfrage durch uns aber
zunehmend auch auf eigeninitiative von
mitarbeitern des erzbistums
wir hatten den eindruck dass dort
zunehmend vertrauen zu uns aufgaben und
es den mitarbeitern des erzbistums eine
herzenssache war und zu unterstützen
bei der sichtung des zur verfügung
gestellten akten materials stellten wir
insbesondere in den alten akten aus
zeitraum der 50er 60er und 70er jahre
zahlreiche dokumente fest die hand
geschrieben waren oder auf denen sich
handschriftliche kürze befanden die
teils nicht lesbar waren beziehungsweise
nicht zugeordnet werden konnten
wir haben das erzbistum in konkrete den
kardinal und den generalvikar hiermit
konfrontiert denkbar und auch rechtlich
zulässig wäre eine ausklammerung dieser
akten bestandteile gewesen mit der folge
dass diese in die gutachterliche
bewertung nicht eingeflossen wären wir
wurden jedoch vom erzbistum gebeten
sämtliche unleserlichen akten
bestandteil und namenskürzel die für
eine umfassende gutachterliche bewertung
von relevanz waren zu identifizieren und
zu übermitteln
diese wurden im anschluss von dem
archivar des erzbistums in
zusammenarbeit mit weiteren mitarbeitern
transkribiert beziehungsweise
namenskürzel zugeordnet so dass wir
diese dann letztlich doch in die
sachverhaltsdarstellung und bewertung
mit einbeziehen konnten uns wurde
mitgeteilt dass wir als erste bezüglich
dieser kürzel und karaffen
beziehungsweise unleserlich keiten
nachgefragt hätten bei der durchsicht
der vom generalvikariat zur verfügung
gestellten dokumente stießen wir auf
zahlreiche listen mit namen die
teilweise eindeutig im zusammenhang mit
sexuellem missbrauch minderjähriger
standen diese listen haben wir dann mit
dem uns überreichten aktenmaterial
abgeglichen und mussten feststellen dass
uns zahlreiche namen unbekannt waren
teilweise war hinter den namen
vernichtet vermerkt so dass das fehlen
und so weit durch die aktenvernichtung
erklärbar war
hinsichtlich der übrigen namen war
jedoch unklar ob für diese person
überhaupt jemals eine akte angelegt
worden war und wenn ja warum diese sich
nicht bei dem überreichen aktenbestand
befand wir sind insgesamt auf 20 namen
gestoßen
die vermutlich im zusammenhang mit
sexuellen missbrauch minderjähriger
stehen und die wähler in den
überreichten akten vorgehen enthalten
sind noch der interventionsstelle
bekannt waren
der umstand dass die aktenführung lange
zeit äußerst mangelhaft war und die
vorgänge vielfach nur lückenlos
lückenhaft dokumentiert sind führte uns
zu der frage wie wir damit umgehen
wir haben uns letztlich dafür
entschieden nicht dokumentierte
vorgänger als nicht geschehen zu
unterstellen wenn andere
erkenntnisquellen nicht das gegenteil
vermuten ließen
findet sich etwa in der akte kein
ernährungsprotokoll des betroffenen und
ergibt sich auch aus der sonstigen
dokumentation wird bei gesprächs
vermerken nicht dass eine solche
stattgefunden hat so sind wir davon
ausgegangen dass es eine anhörung nicht
gegeben hat dies war damit auch geeignet
eine pflichtverletzung zu statuieren
wir haben wir dann die eigentliche
untersuchung durchgeführt
die methode der auswertung wurde
letztlich durch den gutachten auftrag
des erzbistums vorgegeben
zur durchführung wurden zugesagt 236
akten vorgänger übergeben
in einem ersten schritt haben wir das in
den akten abgebildete geschehen
zahlenmäßig konkretisiert
auf diesem wege konnten wir ermitteln
dass sich aus den 236 akten vorgängen
hinweise auf insgesamt 243 beschuldigte
und mindestens 386 individualisierbare
betroffene ergeben
trotz der sortierung des aktenbestand in
der interventionsstelle konnten wir
schon im rahmen der ersten sichtung des
materials feststellen dass in den zur
verfügung gestellten akten auch solche
sachverhalte abgebildet sind die keinen
sexuellen missbrauch bzw
schutzbefohlener zum gegenstand haben
hierfür gibt es zwei gründe im
wesentlichen zwei gründe einerseits
wurden zum teil akten vorgänge zu
verdachtsfällen angelegt für deren
inhaltliche beurteilung das erzbistum
köln gar nicht zuständig war
in diesen fällen erfolgte die
bearbeitung durch ein anderes bistum
beziehungsweise einen orten steht hier
lediglich zu dokumentationszwecken es
sind also keine fälle des erzbistums im
eigentlichen sinne
andererseits betrifft ein teil der akten
verdachtsfälle in denen der betroffene
wieder als minderjähriger noch als
erwachsener schutzbefohlener zu
qualifizieren ist hintergrund sind die
kirchenrechtlichen bestimmungen nach dem
kleriker der besondere verpflichtung zur
enthaltsamkeit unterlegen um wie
empirische akten auswertung auf denen
für die gutachterliche untersuchung
relativ relevanten aktenbestand zu
beschränken haben wir dann in einem
zweiten schritt diejenige verdachtsfälle
ausgesondert in denen entweder kein
minderjähriger beziehungsweise kein
schutzbefohlener betroffen war oder eine
inhaltliche bearbeitung durch das
erzbistum köln langel zuständigkeiten
stattgefunden hat unter berücksichtung
diese eingrenzung verbleiben hinweise
auf 202 beschuldigte und mindestens 314
individualisierbare betroffene die von
uns vor einigen wochen beendeten
genannten zahlen sind also genau so
zutreffend wie die ausführung des
erzbistums kursorisch hier einige
ergebnisse im schnelldurchlauf der
empirischen untersuchung zunächst und
das ist ja ein unterschied auch zu
anderen studien haben wir sowohl fälle
von klerikern und von laien die für das
erzbistum tätig waren
sie sehen dass beschuldigte nach
kirchenrechtlichen status letztlich 63
prozent waren
33 prozent und die akten gerade die
früheren akten das werden sie auch in
den folgenden auswertung sehen haben
nicht immer differenziert zwischen
personen sondern ging es auch teilweise
um einrichtungen so dann haben wir
geguckt im hinblick auf die opfer auf
die betroffenen welchen geschlechts die
sind 57 prozent männlich 38 prozent
weiblich und keine angaben in fünf
prozent der fälle dann haben wir geguckt
welches alter haben die missbrauchten
und mehr als die hälfte bei mehr als der
hälfte der missbrauchten betroffenen
handelt es sich um kinder unter 14
jahren
sodann das war schwierig dazu werden sie
im gutachten lange ausführungen finden
haben wir versucht gruppen von
verschiedenen tatvorwürfen zu bilden
haben natürlich sehr unsere weltliche
strafrechtliche brille aufgesetzt aber
auch dass kirchen strafrecht
berücksichtigt und kommen in rund der
hälfte der fälle zur fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs oder des schweren sexuellen
missbrauchs das wird alles im einzelnen
im gutachten dargestellt dann für uns
sehr wichtig und auch interessant war in
welchem kontext ist die tatbegehung
erfolgt der verein zwei gruppen
natürlich auf zum einen immerhin rund
einem viertel fand die tatbegehung im
rahmen privater treffen also im privaten
umfeld statt
aber insgesamt in den signifikantesten
anteil den ersten drei gruppen ging es
um speziell um betreuungsverhältnisse
was natürlich auch von besonderer
brisanz es kinder jugendbetreuung
internat heimunterbringung
schulunterricht also das sehen sie dann
alles in den einzelnen fall
darstellungen dort wird das auch näher
ausgeführt dann haben wir untersucht in
welcher zeit schien die verdachtsfälle
jetzt sehen sie dass der gang ein ganz
großer teil die zeit vor 1975 viel und
jetzt fragen sich dass wir sollten doch
nur den zeitraum 975 bis 2018
untersuchen aber das ist ein viel
verständnis auch in der öffentlichkeit
wir untersuchen nicht die einzelnen
missbrauchsfälle sondern wir untersuchen
den umgang von verantwortlichen
erzbistums
das heißt
es geht darum es kann genauso gut
passieren dass der missbrauchsfall
selbst 1963 1957 wird teilweise sehr
alten akten oder 1971 stattfand aber
eben erst ab dem jahr 1975 zur anzeige
gebracht wurde oder dem erzbistum
bekannt war und in dem moment fiel es
dann in untersuchungs in unseren
untersuchungszeitraum und großer
bedeutung ist auch die nächste
empirische auswertung die wir gemacht
haben nämlich die verdachtsfälle
nach bekanntwerden und da sehen sie dass
sich jahrzehnte jahrzehnte
offensichtlich niemand getraut hat
solche fälle überhaupt zur anzeige zu
bringen
sie sehen wenn sie zurück gehen ja die
in der folie davor haben sie gesehen
viele verdachtsfälle liegen lange zurück
aber wirklich gemeldet wurden sie erst
das war für uns signifikant mit
aufkommen der missbrauchsdebatte ab dem
jahr 2010
sie haben teilweise jahre halbe
jahrzehnte wie zwischen 1975 und 1979 wo
niemand einen verdachtsfall
beim erzbistum gemeldet hat obwohl der
aus der zuvor dargestellten grafik
wissen dass es dort zu massiven
missbräuchen gekommen ist das ist
nachher auch für die fragen wenn es um
die systemischen ursachen die bewertung
geht von erheblicher bedeutung
zuletzt einen kurzüberblick wie ist das
erzbistum damit umgegangen die
betroffenen wurden in knapp der hälfte
der fälle angehört in den anderen fällen
ist nicht dokumentiert aber unterblieben
die beschuldigten wurden auch in knapp
der hälfte der fälle angehört teilweise
waren natürlich auch ein signifikanter
teil verstorben weil viele
verdachtsfälle erst so spät gemeldet
wurden das sind die
ermittlungsergebnisse wie gesagt nur auf
akten grundlage wir haben die fälle
natürlich nicht im reich wie eine
staatsanwaltschaft das macht im
einzelnen aufgerollt das können wir auch
gar nicht es noch gar nicht möglich weil
viele der beschuldigten ebenso wieder
betroffen natürlich längst verstorben
sind
zuletzt wie sind die gab es die
untersuchungsverfahren in fällen der
kleriker also 69,7 prozent fast 70
prozent bezogen sich der
untersuchungsverfahren auf kleriker
offline ein knappes drittel
und hier haben wir schließlich zuletzt
noch mal was gab es an sanktionen
beziehungsweise an folgen das führt
jetzt zu weit aber das ist alles bei uns
nachgestellt und da sehen sie auch
darauf wird frau dr sterner nachher noch
eingehen das ist schon ein unterschied
gab wie das erzbistum mit klerikern und
laien umgegangen ist
abschließend möchten wir noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass es sich bei den
vorstehenden ausführungen nur um eine
abbildung der akten mäßig dokumentierten
missbrauchsfälle handelt eine etwaige
erfassung der dunkelziffer konnte im
rahmen der akten auswertung naturgemäß
nicht erfolgen in unserem gutachten
einen sehr ausführlichen teil zu den
rechtsgrundlagen finden denn diese sind
natürlich der maßstab für die frage nach
pflichtverletzungen eine
pflichtverletzung ist nur dann
feststellbar wenn zunächst einmal klar
ist welches die einzuhaltenden pflichten
waren
wir haben uns hierbei aber nicht
lediglich auf rechtsnormen beschränkt
sondern auch durch befragungen versucht
die faktischen gegebenheiten im
erzbistum köln einzubeziehen
hierbei hat sich das muss man leider in
dieser deutlichkeit sagen ein bild
ergeben dass über viele jahre von chaos
subjektiv empfundener und zuständigkeit
und missverständnissen geprägt war
geändert hat sich dies jedenfalls
weitestgehend mit der gründung der
interventionsstelle der dort seit 2005
die einzelnen aufgaben in der
bearbeitung von missbrauchsfällen
gebündelt sind
in den jahren zuvor was und uns jedoch
angesichts der vielfach
widersprüchlichen angaben der befragten
schlicht nicht möglich die faktischen
verhältnisse im erzbistum köln mit
gewissheit zu rekonstruieren
im sinne der transparenz haben wir dies
in unserem gutachten sehr ausführlich
dargestellt so dass sich jeder leser und
liebe leserin selbst an
eindruck davon verschaffen kann die aus
den rechtsgrundlagen resultierenden
pflichten haben wir dann in der form
systematisiert dass wir fünf wesentliche
pflichten kreise für die
verantwortungsträger im erzbistum köln
im umgang mit fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs gebildet haben
es handelt sich hierbei um folgenden
pflichten kreise wobei wir wert darauf
legen dass es sich hierbei um die
wesentlichen pflichten handelt zunächst
einmal die aufklärungspflichten dieser
pflichten kreis beinhaltet die pflicht
einem verdacht nachzugehen das heißt
ermittlungen einzuleiten zum zwecke der
erhellung eines sachverhalts und
gegebenenfalls form an eine
kirchenrechtliche voruntersuchung
einzuleiten
zweitens die anzeige und
informationspflichten
hierunter fallen solche verpflichtungen
die der informationsweitergabe dienen
darunter fällt zum einen die kanonische
pflicht zur anzeige eines sachverhalts
gegenüber den strafverfolgungsbehörden
zum anderen die meldung eines
sachverhalts an die glaubenskongregation
in rom
darunter fallen aber auch interne
informationspflichten im erzbistum köln
insbesondere eine berichtspflicht
gegenüber generalvikar und oder
erzbischof drittens die pflicht zur
sanktionierung dieser pflichten kreis
beinhaltet wie der name schon sagt dass
eine sanktionierung zu erfolgen hat wenn
ein nach kanonischem recht strafbares
verhalten feststeht
viertens die verhinderungspflege dieser
pflichten kreis umfasst all jene
pflichten die geeignet und erforderlich
waren um eine drohende tatbegehung zu
verhindern
und fünftens die pflicht so opfer
fürsorge hierunter ist allgemein die
angemessene beschäftigung mit dem opfer
und dessen belangen etwa in form von
anhörungen oder anerkennung des
leistungen zu verstehen
wir haben an dieser stelle in unserem
gutachten ein exkurs eingefügt in
welchem wir uns mit herrn offiziell dr
assenmacher befasst haben
hier konnten seine rolle in der
bearbeitung der missbrauchsfälle nicht
ab
dies erklären er war und ist mitglied in
verschiedenen gremien zum umgang mit
fällen sexuellen missbrauchs und der
ansprechpartner im erzbistum köln wenn
es um fragen des kirchenrechts geht er
selbst sah seine rolle bei der
bearbeitung von missbrauchsfällen als
eher reaktiv an während sich andere
verantwortungsträger darauf verließen
das er erforderliche kirchen rechtliche
schritte vollzug in kirchen rechtlicher
sicht konnten wir konkrete pflichten des
offizialats tatsächlich nicht
feststellen
wir konnten aber in einigen fällen seine
erteilten und auch aus den akten
hervorgehenden rechtsauskünfte
überprüfen und haben dies auch getan
diese pflichten kreise haben sodann die
grundlage für die prüfung der 236
übergebenen akten vorgänger gebildet wir
sind hier nach einem ampelsystem
vorgegangen das heißt jeder einzelne
akten vorgang wurde von uns als grün
gelb oder rot eingeordnet grün bedeutete
im rahmen der bewertung dass der aktuell
kein hinweis zu entnehmen war dass die
jeweilige pflichten kreis verletzt
worden wäre
hierbei sei allerdings nochmals
folgendes bemerkt wir sprechen hier
ausschließlich von pflichtverletzungen
auf akten grundlage das heißt also
keineswegs dass in diesen fällen die wir
als grüne eingeordnet haben auch
tatsächlich alles ordentlich gelaufen
ist die einordnung als gelb wurde
gewählt wenn eine verletzung des
pflichten kreises zwar möglich
erschienen aber nicht sicher bejaht oder
verneint werden konnte etwa weil die
akten zu wenig konkrete anhaltspunkte
enthielten oder weil die rechtslage so
unklar war das eine sichere einordnung
nicht möglich war und wir das gebotene
verhalten nicht eindeutig bestimmen
konnten
eine einordnung als rot haben wir in den
fällen angenommen in denen eine
verletzung des jeweiligen pflichten
kreises eindeutig aus den akten hervor
ging
nach auswertung aller 236 akten sind wir
zu folgendem ergebnis
in 24 akten vorgängen haben die eine
oder mehrere rote markierungen gesetzt
weil in diesen akten vorgängen
mindestens ein eindeutiger
pflichtverstoß feststellbar war
mindestens eine gelbe markierung wurde
in 104 akten vorgängen gesetzt in bezug
auf 108 akten vorgänger war die
bearbeitung ausweislich der aktenlage
nicht zu beanstanden wohlgemerkt
ausweislich der aktenlage herr professor
gerhard bereits darauf hingewiesen dass
wir letztlich nicht dinge begutachten
konnten die sich in den akten nicht
widerspiegelten
die 24 roten akten vorgänger bildeten
dann die grundlage für die untersuchung
im hinblick auf die individuellen
verantwortlichkeiten dazu folgendes
vorab keiner der akten vorgänger die ein
fehlverhalten eines laien zum gegenstand
hatten weist einen eindeutigen
pflichtenverstoß auf hinsichtlich dieser
personengruppe konnten wir regelmäßig
konsequente und zügige reaktionen wie
etwa die kündigung des betreffenden
arbeitnehmers beobachten
das ist selbstverständlich auch darauf
zurückzuführen dass kleriker durch die
in koordination in einem besonderen
verhältnis zu ihrem arbeitgeber stehen
dieses verhältnis ist ähnlich dem eines
beamten zum start durch besondere treue
und fürsorgepflichten geprägt und
schließt eine einfache arbeitsrechtliche
kündigung aus darüber hinaus stellten
wir keine pflichtverstöße von
verantwortungsträgern fest aus denen
sich eine strafbarkeit nach den normen
des weltlichen rechts ergibt wir standen
allerdings in engem kontakt mit der
staatsanwaltschaft köln wir haben
bereits kurz nach unserer mandatierung
das gutachten der münchner kollegen an
die staatsanwaltschaft übergeben
diese laufend über unsere begutachtung
informiert ihr im februar einen ersten
zwischenbericht übergeben und das
fertige gutachten an diesem montag
überreicht damit die staatsanwaltschaft
als die hierfür zuständige behörde die
möglichkeit hat die
ermittlungsergebnisse nach weltlichen
recht zu prüfen
wir haben bei unseren bewertungen die
pflichtverletzung in objektiver hinsicht
geprüft
die feststellung eines objektiven
fehlverhaltens impliziert dabei aber
nicht dass der jeweilige
verantwortungsträger auch vorsätzlich
handelte diese subjektive komponente im
einzelfall nachzuprüfen bei uns verwehrt
und auch nicht teil des gutachten
auftrags war das fehlverhalten im
einzelfall eindeutig auf einen irrtum
etwa hinsichtlich der rechtslage
zurückzuführen fand dieser umstand im
einzelfall als entlastendes moment in
der bewertung erwähnung
wir haben bei unserer bewertung
lediglich normen berücksichtigt die in
zusammenhang mit sexuellen missbrauch
sexualisierter gewalt oder
grenzverletzungen von beziehungsweise an
minderjährigen und schutzbefohlenen
entstehen verhaltensweisen die bloß eine
kirchenrechtliche strafbarkeit wegen
homosexualität oder wegen eines
verstoßes nach sich ziehen wurden nicht
als relevanter verdachtsfall im sinne
dieses gutachten auftrags behandelt sie
bezogen die pflicht zur verhinderung
weiterer taten lediglich auf drohen
sexuellen missbrauch sexualisierte
gewalt oder grenzverletzungen von
beziehungsweise an minderjährigen oder
schutzbefohlenen nach dem täglichen
strafrecht zum zeitpunkt der jeweiligen
fall behandlung
das bedeutet umgekehrt die dinge nicht
davon aus die verantwortungsträger
treffe die pflicht jegliches kirchen
strafrechtlich relevantes verhalten zu
verhindern etwa den einfachen tricks
verstoß bei der anonymisierung sind wir
der gestalt vorgegangen dass wir die
personen gegen die der vorwurf sexuellen
missbrauchs erhoben wurden als
beschuldigte bezeichnet haben und zwar
unabhängig davon ob die tat nachgewiesen
wurde oder ob es bei einem verdachtsfall
blieb personen die angeblich oder
nachweislich opfer sexuellen missbrauchs
wurden haben wir als betroffene
bezeichnet wobei in den fällen in denen
aus einem akten vorgang mehr als ein
betroffener hervorging die betroffenen
regelmäßig mit den buchstaben mit
buchstaben beginnt mit a bezeichnet
wurden die initialen des vor und
nachnamens von beschuldigten und
betroffenen haben wir nicht verwendet
wir haben auch darauf verzichtet
weihbischöfe namentlich zu benennen
da ihnen nach maßgabe des kanonischen
und des weltlichen rechts keine
pflichten oblagen und sie auf ein
tatsächlicher hinsicht dies haben die
anhörung bestätigt über keine
entscheidungskompetenzen verfügten sie
waren und sind zwar mitglieder der
personal konferenz in
personalangelegenheiten kommt ihnen aber
allenfalls eine beratende funktion zu
wir verkennen hierbei nicht dass
weihbischöfe als bindeglied zwischen
bistumsleitung und den einzelnen verein
eine tragende rolle innehaben und ihnen
etwa im rahmen regelmäßiger visitationen
vor ort durchaus missbrauchsfälle oder
auflagen verstöße gemeldet worden sein
könnten
ob und wenn ja in welchen fällen das
geschah sowie die frage wie der einzelne
weihbischof in einem solchen fall
reagiert hat kann auf akten grundlage
jedoch nicht beantwortet werden da die
diesbezügliche kommunikation meist auf
informeller ebene erfolgte und nicht
dokumentiert wurden
sofern die beteiligung von weihbischöfen
im einzelfall aus den akten hervor ging
haben wir diesen umstand in die
sachverhaltsdarstellung aufgenommen
auch in diesen fällen sind ihnen auf
akten grundlage jedoch keine
pflichtverletzung vorzuwerfen dass unser
studie im hinblick auf die persönlichen
pflichtverletzung als ergebnis der
untersuchung ist festzuhalten
versteinertes angesprochen dass wir in
insgesamt 24 der insgesamt 24 akten
vorgänger identifizieren konnten
in dem zeitraum von 1975 bis 2018
eindeutige pflichtverletzung
feststellbar waren innerhalb der 24
akten vorgänger stellten wir zum teil
mehrere pflichtverletzungen fest das
heißt sowohl pflichtverletzung
verschiedener personen als auch mehrere
pflichtverletzung einer person
insgesamt kommen wir auf 75
pflichtverletzung diese wurden von acht
lebenden und verstorbenen personen
begangen
wichtig ist folgendes die getroffene
feststellung beziehen sich
ausschließlich auf das identifizierte
fehlverhalten von früheren oder
aktuellen verantwortungsträgern des
erzbistums köln im umgang mit gemeldeten
missbrauchsfällen im zeitraum von 1975
bis 2018
eine aussage über den wahrheitsgehalt
und die nachweisbarkeit der
zugrundeliegenden verdachtsmeldung wird
und kann hiermit nicht getroffen werden
die tatsache dass ist mir ganz wichtig
dass in dem weit überwiegenden anteil
von 212 8 vorgehen keine
pflichtverletzung von uns identifiziert
wurden bedeutet keineswegs dass es hier
nicht gleichwohl zur pflicht
verletzungen gekommen sein kann
diese waren für uns jedoch auf der akten
grundlage nicht oder jedenfalls nicht
mit der erforderlichen sicherheit
feststellbar und zur qualität der akten
habe ich mich ja nun schon geäußert wir
konnten lediglich begutachten was in den
akten beziehungsweise unterlagen
dokumentiert war und was wir im rahmen
der anhörung und informativen befragung
erfahren haben die durchgeführte
bewertung der fälle steht aus
juristischer sicht ein suchfunktionen
vorgang da also die unterordnung eines
sachverhalts unter die voraussetzungen
einer norm das ist als juristen unser
tägliches brot dass es unsere spielwiese
rechtsnormen und das recht als ganzes
nicht immer eindeutig sind hat der
bewerter bei einem solchen vorgang
regelmäßig ein spielraum innerhalb
dessen er sich zwischen
unterschiedlichen auffassungen zu einer
und derselben rechtsfrage entscheiden
kann und muss wir haben vorliegend
tendenziell eine strengere sichtweite
versteht vertreten auch wenn an einigen
stellen eine für die
verantwortungsträger günstigere oder
mildere auffassung ebenfalls vertretbar
gewesen wäre und zur ablehnung einer
pflichtverletzung geführt hätte wir
wissen dies und hierüber gab es bereits
im vorfeld auseinandersetzung mit
befragten verantwortlichen aber auch
lebhafte diskussionen unter uns anwältin
mit und ohne die beiden kirchenrechtler
allerdings hielten wir vor dem
hintergrund dass dieses gutachten der
aufklärung und verbesserungen und nicht
der verurteilung dienen soll eine
strengere bewertung für angezeigt es ist
daher nur fair und sollte auch bei einer
fairen berichterstattung der liebenden
aber auch verstorbenen verantwortlichen
berücksichtigung finden dass wir hier
einen strengen maßstab anlegen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie bei
diesen maßstäben in deutschland ein bis
zu finden indem wir keine
pflichtverletzungen festgestellt hätten
da wir im zuge der bearbeitung immer
wieder bezüge zu anderen bistümern etwa
den zu fragen bistümern essen oder trier
aber auch anderen erzbistümern hatten
schließen wir sogar aus dass es dort
keine pflichtverletzung gab untersucht
haben wir das natürlich nicht im
eigentlichen sinne
da es nicht in unserem auftrag erfasst
war kommen wir nun zu dem von uns
festgestellten pflichtverletzungen
einzelnen hinsichtlich erzbischofs
professor doktor höffner konnten wir
insgesamt acht pflichtverletzung
feststellen die sich auf sechs
verschiedene akten vorgänger bezogen
hierbei handelt es sich um sechs
verstöße gegen die aufklärungspflicht
und um zwei verstöße gegen die pflicht
zur opfer fürsorge hinsichtlich
erzbischof dr meißner stellt mir
insgesamt 24 pflichtverletzungen fest
die sich auf 14 verschiedene akten
vorgänger bezogen hierbei handelt es
sich um sechs verstöße gegen die
aufklärungspflicht neun verstöße gegen
die meldepflicht zwei verstöße gegen die
sanktionierung pflicht einen verstoß
gegen die verhinderungspflege und fünf
verstöße gegen die pflicht zur opfer
fürsorge herr doktor meißner trifft
mithin allein rund ein drittel aller von
uns festgestellten pflichtverletzung
überdies in voller bandbreite der
unterschiedlichen von festgestellten
arten einer pflichtverletzung
hinsichtlich erzbischof woelki konnten
wir keine pflichtverletzung erkennen
wenn einige theologen oder journalisten
in den vergangenen wochen dies ohne
kenntnis der akten und ohne befragung
von herrn woelki und anderen beteiligten
anders sehen als wir ist das ihr gutes
recht
es scheint dabei allerdings etwa in
vergessenheit zu geraten dass wir nicht
rückwirkend recht anwenden können
insbesondere nicht die empfehlung aus
dem vademecum aus 2020 für einen vorgang
aus 2011 oder 2015 zugrunde liegen
können wir liegen mit unserer wertung
die wird sich leicht gemacht haben den
medial wäre es für uns am einfachsten
gewesen ein wirklicher zum stadt
fortzuführen
aber wir liegen mit dieser wertung nicht
nur auf linie mit dem heiligen stuhl
sondern übrigens auch mit den münchner
kollegen allerdings mit einem kleinen
unterschied
ein kollege aus der münchner kanzlei
hatte die referenten des kardinals
bereits im vergangenen frühjahr darüber
informiert
das dem kardinal nichts ruhe und er sich
keine sorgen machen brauchen das ist mir
doch im blick auf die berichterstattung
der vergangenen monate wichtig auch wenn
ich da das räume ich ein die rolle des
gutachters kurz verlassen hätte der
kardinal wirklich etwas bezüglich seiner
eigenen person zu vertuschen gehabt
hätte er das münchner gutachten
durchwinken können ein rechtsstaat
riskieren können und hätte persönlich
seine ruhe gehabt er wusste ja dass er
einem gutachten kann ich auftauchen
würde
diesen umstand haben wir erst vor kurzem
in der befragung des kardinals anfang
februar erfahren wir haben ihn als
letzten befragt und sodann hierzu seine
referenten angefragt die uns einen
entsprechenden gesprächsvermerk und
handschriftlichen notizen zu diesem
telefonat übersandt hat den
verantwortungsträgern unterhalb der
ebene des erzbischofs hinsichtlich
generalvikar dr feldhoff konnten wir
insgesamt 13 pflichtverletzungen
feststellen die sich auf acht
verschiedene akten vorgänger bezogen
hierbei handelte es sich um sieben
verstöße gegen die aufklärungspflicht
und sechs verstöße gegen die pflicht zur
opfer fürsorge hinsichtlich generalvikar
dr schwaderlapp haben wir insgesamt acht
pflichtverletzungen festgestellt die
sich auf fünf verschiedene akten
vorgänger bezogen
hierbei handelte es sich um zwei
verstöße gegen die aufklärungspflicht
und sechs verstöße gegen die
meldepflicht hinsichtlich ein doktor
haase aktuell erzbischof von hamburg
haben wir insgesamt elf
pflichtverletzungen festgestellt die
sich auf neun verschiedene akten
vorgänger bezogen auf seine amtszeit als
leiter der hauptabteilung seelsorge
personal empfehlen 7 nicht ordnungsgemäß
bearbeitete fälle
darin kam es zu fünf verstößen gegen die
aufklärungspflicht und zwei verstößen
gegen die meldepflicht auf seine
amtszeit als generalvikar sowie auf
seine amtszeit als diözesanadministrator
entfielen 3 nicht ordnungsgemäß
bearbeitete fälle
darin kam es zu einem verstoß gegen die
aufklärungspflicht und drei verstößen
gegen die meldepflicht hinsichtlich
eines leiters der hauptabteilung
seelsorge personal haben wir in einem
akten vorgang eine pflichtverletzung
festgestellt hierbei handelte es sich um
einen verstoß gegen die
aufklärungspflicht mit blick auf die
vorgaben des äußerung rechts
haben wir hier nach absprache mit dem
hierfür mandatierten spezialisten dr
carsten brennecke von der kanzlei höcker
auf eine namentliche nennung verzichtet
hinsichtlich einer justiziarin des
erzbistums köln konnten wir insgesamt
neun pflichtverletzungen in sieben akten
vorgängen feststellen
hierbei handelte es sich durchweg um
verstöße gegen die meldepflicht und zwar
in der form einer unterlassenen anzeige
über den strafverfolgungsbehörden auch
für die justiziarin gilt dass wir sich
aus den gleichen gründen nicht
namentlich benannt haben
hinsichtlich offizial dr assenmacher
haben die in zwei fällen festgestellt
dass die durch ihn erteilte
rechtsauskunft unzutreffend war
uns ist bewusst dass die feststellung
von pflichtverletzungen bezüglich an dr
assenmacher als offizial sehr streng ist
ja wusste jedoch als mitglied des
berater stabs der personal konferenz
sowie das von herrn generalvikar dr
schwaderlapp einberufenen informellen
gremiums um die konkreten
missbrauchsfälle auf bestehende defizite
im bereich der norm befolgung wies herr
doktor assenmacher allerdings nicht hin
für uns und sicherlich auch für das
erzbistum wesentlich wichtiger als die
frage nach persönlichen
pflichtverletzungen ist die frage nach
den ursachen für die festgestellten
pflicht fälle zu und auch an dieser
stelle nochmal ganz wichtig es geht
nicht um die möglichen ursachen für
sexuellen missbrauch als solchen in der
katholischen kirche das ist aufgabe
anderer disziplinen etwa von
kriminologen oder soziologen fragen wie
das zölibat männerbünde die rolle der
frau in der kirche sind alles wichtige
fragen es sind aber keine juristischen
fragen die von juristen zu klären sind
wenn juristen sich hierzu verhalten
verlassen sie ihren bereich das ist eine
faire so als würde ich ihnen was über
kieferchirurgie erzählen dazu habe ich
eine meinung aber keine ausgewiesene
kompetenz unser auftragsbestand
letztlich daran die gründe für die
festgestellten defizite bei der
rechtlichen behandlung der
verdachtsfälle ans licht zu bringen das
ist eine aufgabe für juristen und diese
haben wir wahrgenommen
die wesentlichen probleme punkte lagen
aus unserer sicht mit unserer
juristischen perspektive in einem
unklaren norm gefüge einem fehlenden
bewusstsein
von der notwendigkeit der rechts
befolgung und einer massiven rechts
unkenntnis der verantwortungsträger dass
norman gefüge als auf das wie im
kirchenrecht in bezug auf die behandlung
von missbrauchsfällen stießen ist von
unklarheit und widersprüchlichkeit
geprägt wir waren mit stark auslegungs
bedürftigen beziehungsweise zu wenig
klare normen konfrontiert die bislang
nahezu keine konkretisierung erfahren
haben
überdies waren und sind etliche normen
den rechtsanwender nicht bekannt und
dies dass es aus sicht eines weltlichen
rechtsanwender es überhaupt nicht
vorstellbar
sie können auch gar nicht bekannt seien
weil sie nicht veröffentlicht wurden
beziehungsweise weil sie sogar geheim
gehalten wurden jeweiligen akten inhalte
sowie die anhörung ergebnisse legen nahe
dass den verantwortungsträgern das
bewusstsein dafür fehlte das gesetz oder
unter gesetzliche regeln die norm
anwender binden und es grundsätzlich
unzulässig ist sich aus
zweckmäßigkeitserwägungen oder sonstigen
subjektiv nachvollziehbar erscheinen
gründen über die vorgaben hinwegzusetzen
es mag den verantwortungsträgern im
einzelfall schneller und einfacher
erschienen sein pastorale schritte zu
wählen als die vorgeschriebenen
verfahrenswege einzuhalten
es fehlte offensichtlich das bewusstsein
dafür dass die einhaltung formalisierter
verfahrenswege gerade kein selbstzweck
ist sondern einen strukturierten und für
alle beteiligten nachvollziehbaren
rahmen schafft und die basis für
transparente und rechtssichere
entscheidungen bildet schließlich
herrschte eine ausgeprägte rechts
unkenntnis bei allen beteiligten in
bezug auf die für den umgang mit
sexuellen missbrauch minderjähriger und
schutzbefohlener einschlägigen normen
das ist nach unserer auffassung auf die
bereits erwähnte intransparenten
umsetzung zurückzuführen wenn
vorschriften geheim gehalten werden
nicht allgemein verkündet oder erst
deutlich nach ihrem inkrafttreten
veröffentlicht werden ist rechts
unkenntnis die logische folge eng
verwoben mit den problemen punkten der
rechts und kenntnis und fielen in rechts
befolgung ist der umstand dass
zuständigkeiten im märz
in köln widerrechtlich noch faktisch
klar waren
das hat sich erst mit der last der
leitlinien anfang der 2000er gewandelt
ist aber durchaus noch ausbaufähig
erhebliche defizite stellten wir der
aktenführung fest dazu hat herr
professor gehrke ja schon einiges gesagt
ich denke hier auch an dieser stelle im
einzelnen einzugehen würde alleine
mehrere stunden dauern
aber hier ist dringend abhilfe geboten
nach unserem eindruck löste die welle
anmeldungen im jahr 2010 geradezu über
forderungen bei den
verantwortungsträgern aus
das war möglicherweise der grund das
verfahrensschritte vergessen wurden oder
sich die bearbeitung der fälle stark
verzögerte die überforderung markt
zusätzlich dadurch verstärkt worden sein
dass zugaben ist die befragten nahezu
übereinstimmend an sie niemals auf ihre
aufgaben vorbereitet wurden von
mitarbeiterschulungen oder fortbildungen
zum thema des umgangs mit sexuellen
missbrauch wusste keiner der angehörten
verantwortungsträger zu berichten
ursächlich für fehlentwicklungen
insbesondere für sich über längere zeit
verfestigte defizite dürften außerdem
die fehlenden internen wie externen
kontrollmechanismen gewesen sein
darüber hinaus gab es bei der
bearbeitung von missbrauchsfällen lange
zeit wenig austausch mit anderen
fachrichtungen der einen
perspektivenwechsel ermöglicht hätte als
jedenfalls mit öl ursächlich für den
besonders problematischen aspekt dass
die betroffenen lange zeit keine
zuwendung erfuhren ist sicherlich auch
dass die sonst so strenge sexualmoral
der katholischen kirche im falle
sexueller übergriffe durch kleriker
nicht konsequent zur geltung kam
es geht wieder um womöglich darauf
zurück dass gemäß der katholischen lehre
sämtliche sexuelle handlungen sofern
eben außerhalb der ehe vollzogen als
verstoß gegen das sechste gebot des
dialogs qualifiziert werden diese
handlungen sind allesamt sündhaft der
sexuelle missbrauch von kindern oder
schutzbefohlenen war lange zeit nur
deshalb von kirchen strafrecht erfasst
weil sich der täter dadurch schwer gegen
seine amtspflicht vergingen nicht etwa
weil die tat aus opferperspektive
als besonders schwerwiegend beurteilt
wurde schließlich unter vielen tagen an
über 16 jährigen bis 2001 nicht im
tatbestand des sexuellen missbrauchs
minderjähriger diese sichtweise
versperrte einen adäquaten blick auf die
leiden der betroffenen und das gewicht
der tathandlungen wir haben in den
letzten monaten sehr auf das wort
vertuschung lesen und hören können
zuletzt gerade wieder vom vorsitzenden
der deutschen bischofskonferenz
dahinter steht die überlegung dass ein
problem eines so großen ausmaßes nur
deshalb für lange zeit unentdeckt
bleiben konnte
weil es personen gegeben haben musste
oder immer noch gibt die an
bekanntwerden werden der fälle
verhinderten
teilweise wird auch vermutet vertuschung
sei systematisch betrieben worden
im erzbistum köln gab es immer wieder
bestrebungen von einzelnen
verantwortungsträgern fälle sexuellen
missbrauchs nicht öffentlich werden zu
lassen
zum zwecke der erreichung dieses ziels
wurden bestimmte verhaltensweisen selbst
verwirklicht angewiesen oder fried
pflichtwidrig unterlassen
sie finden dazu diverse beispiele in aus
den akten in unserem gutachten sprechen
für sich selbst wenn es etwa heißt dinge
nicht an die große glocke hängen zu
wollen
für uns war keine absicht der
verantwortungsträger erkennbar die täter
einer bestrafung zu entziehen oder gar
weitere missbrauchstaten zu ermöglichen
vielmehr ging es offenbar darum
reputationsschäden von der kirche
abzuwenden und den einzelnen
beschuldigten weiter im system kirche zu
lassen
ebenfalls nicht erkennbar ist ein
planvolles kreatives zusammenwirken
mehrerer personen oder gar eine
dienstanweisung von oben viel mehr
drängte sich das bild eines völlig
unkoordinierten ja teilweise planlosen
handelns auf das macht es im ergebnis ja
keinen deut besser
wir sind auf ein system der
unzuständigkeit der fehlenden
rechtsklarheit der fehlenden
kontrollmöglichkeiten und der
intransparenz gestoßen dass
geheimhaltung jedenfalls begünstigte und
an dem viele beteiligte mitwirkten auch
außerhalb des erzbistums
dementsprechend würden wir streng
genommen nicht von systematischer
vertuschung sprechen wohl aber von
systembedingte oder system in der renter
vertuschen
sie haben jetzt vier pflichtverletzung
und systemischen ursachen hierfür gehört
die aufarbeitung der vergangenheit war
wichtig und richtig und persönlich denke
ich dass diese aufarbeitung auch nicht
mit unseren juristischen gutachten
abgeschlossen sein kann
wir möchten im erzbistum gleichwohl
entsprechend unserem gutachten auftrag
einige handlungsempfehlungen aus
juristischer sicht mit auf den weg geben
und zwar jenseits von
personalentscheidungen rücktritten
freistellung etc
wir denken dass man an die strukturellen
defizite ran muss um zukünftig
individuelle pflichtverletzung zu
vermeiden
wir haben hierfür in unserem gutachten
diverse vorschläge aus juristischer
sicht gemacht die wir hier an dieser
stelle nur kursorisch kurz
zusammenfassen
der erste punkt ist die anpassung der
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen
das kann natürlich vom erzbistum köln
nicht alleine bewirkt werden
aber das erzbistum kann versuchen darauf
hinzuwirken in rom und bei der deutschen
bischofskonferenz auf eine
fortentwicklung des universalen
kirchenrechts auf eine beseitigung nach
wie vor bestehende widersprüche zwischen
der missbrauchs ordnung der deutschen
bischofskonferenz und den vorschriften
des gesamt kirchlichen rechts und
schließlich das kann hier vor ort
geschehen eine vereinheitlichung der
rechtsanwendung ein punkt der sich
ausschließlich an das erzbistum
adressiert weil das jedes erzbistum für
sich selbst klären muss ist eine von uns
vehement geforderte stärkung der
interventionsstelle es muss eine
optimierung von zuständigkeitsverteilung
und aufgabenbeschreibung geben ganz
maßgeblich ist auch die verbesserung der
aktenführung das ist ja heute mehrfach
angeklungen hier liegt ein ganz
wesentliches problem
es müssen die für jede weltliche behörde
geltenden grundsätze der akten
vollständigkeit und akten wahrheit
umgesetzt werden das fängt mit so
einfachen dingen wie einer pardini rung
also der verwendung von durchgehenden
seitenzahlen an damit man sehen kann ob
aus der akte was herausgenommen oder
hinzugefügt wurde
ganz einfach die beschränkung der
aktenführung befugnis damit klar ist wer
hatte zugriff auf die akte und damit
einhergehend der schutz vor unbefugten
zugriff auf akten
der schutz vor vorzeitiger vernichtung
und erhaltung der akten struktur und
soweit regen wir dringend erste schritte
sind unterwegs ja die umsetzung des
erlasses einer verbindlichen akten
ordnung an die einführung von
standardisierten bearbeitungsprozesse
wie sie gesagt in unternehmen oder
weltlichen behörden schon lange gelten
für die interventionsstelle muss eine
unabhängige aufarbeitung gewährleistet
sein
das fängt an mit einer strukturellen
trennung der interventionsstelle von der
des offizialats wir regen an auch wenn
wir wissen dass das mit einigen
ressourcen verbunden ist nicht ganz
einfach aber da kann das erzbistum eine
vorreiterrolle nehmen den aufbau einer
kompetenzstelle für kirchen strafrecht
auf ebene der exekutive weiterhin frau
dr stern hat des angesprochenen
anforderung spezifischere fortbildung
damit der zustand der überforderung der
im letzten jahrzehnt hier offensichtlich
gegolten hat damit dem abhilfe
geschaffen werden kann
weiterhin soll die interventionsstelle
die möglichkeit haben sich auf die
arbeit bearbeitung von aktuellen
verdachtsmeldungen zu konzentrieren dass
die geschäftsstelle muss eingerichtet
ausgebaut werden und davon zu trennen
ist die opfer nachbetreuung die
betroffenen nachsorge das ist eine
eigenständige aufgabe für die sie nach
unserer vorstellung entsprechend auch
personal schaffen müssen
und schließlich etwas was in jedem
kleineren mittelständischen unternehmen
heute schon gang und gäbe ist der ausbau
von wirklich geschützten
hinweisgebersystem weg von informellen
meldungen hin zu einem
hinweisgebersystem etwa der schaffung
der stelle eines ombudsmannes und einer
sogenannten whistleblower hotline
weiterer punkt der auch im sinne der
glaubwürdigkeit aus unserer sicht
erforderlich ist dass sanktionierung von
fehlverhalten auch umgesetzt wird
das heißt insbesondere die
sanktionierung von verstößen gegen
bistums und terrorismus und herne
meldepflichten und eine klare
kommunikation der konnte
setzten zuletzt vernünftiges monitoring-
und wissensmanagement das heißt die
einführung eines zentralen
verfahrensregister die obligatorische
berücksichtigung der erkenntnisse der
intervention interventionsstelle bei
personalentscheidungen und der
informationsaustausch mit anderen
bistümern
vor 30 40 jahren was auch so wenn sie in
hessen gewohnt haben und da hatte die
örtliche polizei erkenntnisse über sie
haben das bundesland gewechselt weil
polizei ländersache ist konnte es sein
dass wenn sie nach nrw gezogen sind sie
aus den augen aus dem sinn war das ist
heute mit blick auf die
datenverarbeitung im polizeilichen
bereich natürlich nicht mehr der fall
aber so ist es teilweise bei den
bistümern die einrichtung eines internen
kontroll- und evaluierungs systems die
einführung ein ganz wesentliches problem
einer stelle zur überwachung der
einhaltung von auflagen
denn es gab fälle wo sanktioniert wurde
wo auflagen erteilt wurde das hat noch
niemand sich darum kümmert über die
überwachung und schließlich ganz
wesentlich die turnusmäßige
berichtspflicht an den ordinarius das
schafft verantwortung
schließlich gab es einige fälle wo wir
letztlich nicht zur pflicht koalition
gekommen sind weil wir nicht nachweisen
konnten mit der erforderlichen
sicherheit dass der ordinarius auch über
den fall unterrichtet war meine damen
und herren das waren kurz
zusammengefasst unsere ergebnisse aus
etwas mehr als fünf monaten sehr
intensiver arbeit mit weit mehr als den
vier antreten und den zwei
kirchenrechtler ich möchte mich hier
insbesondere bei frau doktor eckmann und
hoster forstmann bedanken die gemeinsam
mit frau doktor stiller und mir das
gutachten verantworten aber auch bei
allen anderen anwälten unserer kanzlei
insbesondere dr kürzinger dr
wohlschläger und frau dr himbach die
hier mitgearbeitet haben und die
wirklich in vergangen monaten
unfassbares geleistet haben wir möchten
uns auch
an dieser stelle bei den vielen
mitarbeitern und mitarbeiterinnen des
erzbistums bedanken die uns ohne
rücksicht auf sehr prominente namen in
der geschichte dieses erzbistums
unterstützt haben ja alle wissen namen
wie kardinal meisner haben hier in köln
für viele menschen legendenstatus wir
möchten uns besonders bedanken für die
anregung und unterstützung des
betroffenen beirats der selbst
anfeindungen ausgesetzt war
für den betroffenen beirat und den
kardinal haben wir ein exemplar im
ausdruck zur übergabe über die übrigen
mitglieds betroffenen beirats
entschädigung hatte es angesprochen
werden von uns ein ausgedrucktes
exemplar enthalten das gutachten wird
dann um 13 uhr für die öffentlichkeit
online gestellt ich denke mir dass sie
viele fragen haben bitten sie die auf
das zu beschränken was wir ihnen heute
mitgeteilt haben
danach sollten sie vielleicht erst
einmal die 800 seiten lesen und können
sich dann natürlich auch gerne an uns
oder das bist du wenden
ich gehe aber davon aus dass nunmehr wie
als gutachter wieder in den hintergrund
treten können und das erz bistum selbst
am zug ist wichtig ist auch wir werden
zu keinem der einzelfälle jetzt im
detail fragen beantworten das gutachten
ist und soweit selbsterklärend und wenn
wir dort keine weiteren angaben gemacht
haben dann hat das seinen guten grund
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr professor werke vielen
dank frau doktor stirn ja das war jetzt
präzise eine stunde die pressekonferenz
die wir jetzt schon mal mitverfolgt
haben professor gehrke und seiner
kollegin dr stürmer haben das gutachten
vorgestellt es ist wir sprechen jetzt
erst mal darüber mit jürgen erbacher
hier im studio sagen aber gleich dazu
dass wir sofort wieder live rübergehen
nach köln
wenn das gutachten dann überreicht wird
an den erzbischof an kardinal woelki
jetzt können dort die journalisten erst
mal fragen stellen aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen jürgen wenn wir da jetzt
eine stunde zugehört haben ich weiß
nicht wo man anfangen soll ich glaube
ich habe 99 fragen an dich das ist
irgendwie schon
starker tobak oder gutes sind sage mal
das ist glaube ich so gemischt wenn man
die letzte stunde jetzt so revue
passieren lässt auf der einen seite ist
klar dieses gutachten ist wieder nur in
anführungszeichen einen baustein
es bedeutet nicht dass jetzt der
missbrauch im erzbistum köln komplett
aufgearbeitet ist sondern dazu braucht
es weitere untersuchungen auf der
anderen seite sind jetzt schon ganz klar
auch mal verantwortlichkeiten und namen
benannt und hier wird jetzt das
entscheidende sein
wie gehen die benannten jetzt damit um
wenn man wird natürlich jetzt anschauen
müssen ab heute nachmittag was sind das
denn für konkrete fälle wenn das
gutachten dann veröffentlicht ist und
zum anderen wie geht jetzt kardinal
woelki mit diesem gutachten um und
welche konsequenzen wir daraus ziehen
man könnte ja sagen okay in
anführungsstrichen ist reingewaschen
wobei man ja klar sagen muss professor
gerke hat gesagt dass sie vorsichtig
sind also selbst diejenigen die
sozusagen hier grün gekennzeichnet sind
gegen die jetzt keine verstöße gefunden
werden konnten das heißt nicht dass sie
wirklich die reine weste haben also
alles mit vorsicht zu genießen aber
insofern sind wir alle gespannt was
kardinal woelki dazu sagen wird in
seinem statement aber es stellen sich
doch viele fragen ich meine das urteil
ist doch sehr klar
fehlendes rechtsbewusstsein massive
rechts unkenntnis fehlende rechts
befolgung ein system der unzuständigkeit
und intransparenz und wenn es nicht eine
systematische vertuschung ist wie es
manchmal schon geheißen hat dann doch
zumindest eine systembedingte forschung
ich meine wenn ein unternehmen oder chef
eines unternehmens das hören würde von
ich sag mal in einem orbit von einer
rating agentur oder einem
unternehmensberater ist eher
wahrscheinlich denn gut nehmen oder in
der tat
das sind natürlich klare worte man hat
diese klaren worte sich erwünscht man
hat sie erhofft
das zeigt auch ein bisschen das was was
auch betroffene in den letzten jahren
immer wieder gesagt haben
das mag vielleicht
an vielen stellen gar nicht unbedingt
böser wille gewesen sein wenn es um
vertuschung und verschleppung ging die
zuständigkeiten sind nicht da geregelt
gewesen
die akten ich meine die deutsche
bischofskonferenz hat ja nach
vorstellung dieses großen gutachtens
2018 diese im hg studie von
wissenschaftlern gesagt ja wir nehmen
uns auf jeden fall die akten frage vor
wir müssen irgendwie schauen dass wir
eine vereinheitlichung der richtlinien
und all dieser dinge haben
man muss ganz ehrlich aber auch sagen
ich meine seit zehn jahren wird seit
über zehn jahren wird über diese dinge
diskutiert und da kann man die ungeduld
vieler betroffener und auch vieler
menschen in der republik verstehen dass
die sagen mensch jetzt mussten wir
wieder elf jahre warten bis der
professor gehrke mit seinem team genau
diese punkte benannt hat von denen man
weiß dass die im argen liegen und das
ist natürlich schon ein ja ein
vernichtendes urteil für die
verantwortlichen
und hier sind mit sicherheit dinge schon
in der vergangenheit passiert in vielen
bistümern
aber es wurde jetzt noch mal wird jetzt
hier nochmal ganz klar gesagt hier muss
extremst gehandelt werden hier muss
dringend gehandelt werden
und auch wenn der kardinal der
amtierende erzbischof von köln jetzt
erstmal ein grün habt es gibt durchaus
ja auch unter kirchenrechtler
unterschiedliche bewertungen wie in dem
einen oder anderen fall bei dem er auch
bei dem ihm auch vorgeworfen wird er
habe nicht konsequent gehandelt wie das
kirchenrechtlich zu bewerten ist also da
ist vielleicht auch noch nicht das
letzte wort gesprochen also du sagst
dann das warten da haben viele gewartet
wir haben viele zuschriften schon
bekommen und schicken sie weiter fragen
wir werden noch lange jetzt darüber
reden und nachher auch noch mal mit
patrick bauer einem betroffenen dem er
anfangs ja schon hatten der die
pressekonferenz verfolgt hat darüber
sprechen er wird diese pressekonferenz
jetzt noch weiter verfolgen die fragen
der journalisten
danach kommt das statement von kardinal
woelki dass wir dann live zeigen da
springen wir wieder nach köln und
anschließend der wir mit patrick bauer
also einem betroffenen der im
betroffenen beirat saß und aus protest
zurückgetreten ist also auch noch
intensiv sprechen jetzt haben wir von
morpho über youtube einen kommentar klar
man hat mit den ermittlungen so lange
gewartet bis die
meisten beschuldigten tod waren und so
läuft das immer man muss sagen im fall
von kardinal meisner ist es eben so
den kann man nicht mehr befragen oder
keine reaktion hören interessant ist
auch junos deutschland schreibt über
facebook es wird leider nur ein
schweigegeld gezahlt das leid wird damit
nicht beseitigt ich habe es erlebt denn
ich bin betroffen also für yunus mit
sicherheit auch spannend wenn wir die
fragen gemeinsam diskutieren auch mit
patrick bauer denn das ist ja auch die
naheliegende frage die uns bewegt was
sagen die betroffenen zu dem was wir
alle jetzt gemeinsam gehört haben und
das sind ja doch einige sachen die da
aufhorchen lassen aktenvernichtung massa
kanonischem recht dass man also da steht
und sagt es gibt nichts mehr
handschriften die nicht leserlich sind
und das sind sachen muss ich dich jetzt
einfach fragen jürgen hast du das schon
gehört wir haben jetzt heute erfahren
dass der frühere kölner erzbischof eben
meist nach einen ordner mit akten hatte
über brüder im nebel also seine eigenen
gift akten ja ja also das ist sage ich
mal selber in diesem detail sind die
dinge bisher nicht bekannt gewesen es
ist eigentlich so dass das weiß man
schon dass es in den bistümern über
lange zeit gab es die normalen
personalakte aber professor gerke hat ja
auch von dem berühmten giftschrank
gesprochen wo dann eben noch mal
besondere akten gelagert wurden für die
fälle die eben in besonderer weise nicht
nicht korrekt die die personen sich
verhalten haben das mag zum teil gewesen
sein dass es um delikte gegen das dass
der zölibat gebrochen wurde
es mag es waren aber auch genau die
fälle wo es um missbrauch gehen in
diesen gift schränken normalerweise
wurden die beim erzbischof sozusagen
beim obersten in einem bistum direkt
geführt wir haben jetzt gelernt im falle
vom erzbistum köln ist auch dieser
giftschrank gar nicht wirklich beim beim
kardinal gewesen sondern beim
generalvikar also sozusagen dem dem
alter ego dem obersten verwaltungsmensch
'nen im erzbistum köln
trotzdem hatte der erzbischof noch mal
für sich
eine akte geführt und von daher ist klar
er wusste von den fällen bescheid und
entsprechend wurden ja jetzt auch ich
meinen 24 pflichtverletzungen das sind
jetzt die die professor gehrke mit
seinem team gefunden hat er hat ja
mehrfach betont wir konnten nur aufgrund
der dinge urteilen die wo wir die akten
hatten also reines aktenstudium du hast
es erwähnt das sind akten vernichtet
worden
diese fälle die konnten hier natürlich
auch nicht mehr untersucht werden
also man muss jetzt wenn wir uns das
ganze jahr angehört haben sagen es ist
sehr verständlich jetzt für mich als
absoluten laien das system was jetzt die
juristen hier gemacht haben dass sie
sozusagen das prinzip haben worauf
schauen wir auf welche fünf kriterien
sozusagen aufklärungspflicht da würde
man sagen ja wenn einem verantwortlichen
in so einem bistum ein missbrauchsfall
gemeldet wird dass man dann natürlich
sagt das müssen wir aufklären würde man
sagen selbstverständlichkeit der zweite
punkt anzeige und informationspflicht
nachvollziehbar wie kann man sich
sozusagen dem entziehen drittens pflicht
zur sanktionierung auch da würde der
laie sagen selbstverständlich das
erwarte ich schon verantwortlichen in
der katholischen kirche
wenn sie von einem missbrauchsfall
erfahren dass sie sanktionieren
professor gerke hat ja dann am ende auch
noch gesagt
es mangelt aber auch an überprüfung der
sanktionen selbst wenn sie erlassen
werden die verhinderungspflege also
weitere taten zu verhindern und vor
allen dingen eine opfer fürsorge da
werden wir eben mit patrick bauer auch
nochmal drüber sprechen also fünf
absolut verständliche pflichten wo man
eigentlich gar nicht dran rütteln kann
und trotzdem werden sie eben oder sind
in der vergangenheit von erzbischof
generalvikar neben verletzt worden
ist das dann schon etwas was ein
bisschen heute schockiert oder ist das
eigentlich zu erwarten gewesen
ja ich glaube an vielen stellen wurde es
auch erwartet weil wir haben von den
betroffenen ja immer wieder auch gehört
die ihre fälle geschildert haben die
geschildert haben dass das erzbistum
entweder gar nicht reagiert hat oder mit
großer zeitlicher verzögerung reagiert
hat wieder den einzelfällen mit ihnen
umgegangen wurde
und wenn man das sieht dann dann und
sieht dagegen wie die anweisungen
eigentlich sind in solchen fällen
vorzulegen dann konnte man schon erahnen
dass hier in irgendeiner form dann auch
pflichtverletzungen vorliegen
jetzt sind sie für diese von professor
gehrke genannten fälle jetzt auch mal
konkret wirklich personen zugeordnet und
das ist das was kardinal meisner
kardinal woelki ja von anfang an wollte
als er im herbst 2008 10 das erste
gutachten dann auch in auftrag gegeben
hat er sagte ich will jetzt endlich mal
verantwortliche benannt haben ich möchte
diese strukturen verstehen ich möchte
wissen wer hat wo etwas nicht getan was
er hätte tun sollen
von daher kardinal woelki hat jetzt das
ergebnis dass er möchte es scheint jetzt
auch nach dem verfahren die das
professor gehrke mit seinem mit seiner
kanzlei gewählt hat auch rechtssicher zu
sein von daher können wir das dann heute
mittag 13 uhr nachlesen wie ich vorhin
schon gesagt habe es gibt eine
unterscheidung persönlichkeiten die
sozusagen im öffentlichen leben stehen
wie ein erzbischofs wie ein general
wieker die werden auch persönlich
benannt bei der justiziarin oder dem
einen personalverantwortlichen wo es
wohl eine pflichtverletzung dann noch
gibt die werden nicht namentlich benannt
weil hier kein öffentliches interesse
besteht und jetzt ist die die
entscheidende frage dass man sich die
einzelnen fälle noch mal anschaut und
dann ist die frage wie wird jetzt zum
beispiel erzbischof hieße der ja für wie
viele waren es 11 pflichtverletzungen
hier identifiziert wurden wie wird er
jetzt darauf reagieren wie wird er
handeln
wie wird er hat ja auch den vatikan
eingeschaltet schon der sozusagen die
vorwürfe dann auch prüfen soll gegen ihn
was wird daraus entstehen und dann was
macht karin alberti daraus ja dann sind
wir gleich bei den fragen von unseren
usern frank maatz geschafft
richtigerweise ich frage mich was der
papst dazu sagt denn wir haben hier eine
pressekonferenz im erzbistum köln aber
dass es auch schon gesagt das sind ja
informationen die auch nach oben gehen
und der vatikan wird gespannt da
zuschauen
rechnest du mit irgendwelchen
kommentaren konsequenzen anordnungen aus
rom
also mit sicherheit wird an mehreren
stellen im vatikan jetzt hier der
livestream aus köln mit verfolgt oder
man schaut sich im fernsehen an
der papst selber sicherlich nicht er hat
andere dinge heute zu tun
ich habe ja bereits erwähnt erzbischof
heese hat sich an den vatikan schon
gewendet auch kardinal woelki hat sich
im dezember ja schon an den vatikan
gewendet da gibt es unterschiedliche
interpretationen ob man ihn
freigesprochen hat in bezug auf die
frage ob er pflichtverletzungen begangen
hat oder nicht aber natürlich man nimmt
es im vatikan sehr aufmerksam war
und natürlich wird der vatikan jetzt
dann auch nach sichtung der gutachten
zumindest wenn es um personen geht wie
erzbischof heese auch der ehemalige
generalvikar schwaderlapp ja jetzt
weihbischof ist in im erzbistum köln
natürlich wird der vatikan dann in
irgendeiner form reagieren weil welche
handlungsoptionen hat der kardinal
der kann jetzt also will der kann jetzt
in bezug auf erzbischof asse in hamburg
kann er gar nichts tun
in bezug auf den war auf einen
weihbischof kann er auch nichts tun weil
der papst ernennt den weihbischof der
kant könnte jetzt zwar sagen ich
entziehe dir deine zuständigkeiten hier
stellt ihn sozusagen kalt aber der
weihbischof bleibt trotzdem weihbischof
also in bestimmten punkten muss dann
unter umständen der vatikan handeln weil
es gar nicht im machtbereich von
kardinal woelki steht dann da etwas zu
tun
in vielen anderen punkten die jetzt
benannt wurden diese lange liste gerade
am ende von empfehlungen die professor
gehrke jetzt abgegeben hat da hat er
viel zu tun
eine frage die user und ich mir ja auch
immer wieder stelle ist oder die in den
letzten wochen ja auch schon gestellt
worden ist ist ganz einfach nach
dann treten sie doch einfach zurück
sozusagen wenn diese vorwürfe da sind
wenn diese verfehlungen da sind wenn
diese fehler gemacht worden sind dann
sage ich mal müsste sie erzbischof käse
oder herr schwaderlapp dann treten sie
doch zurück da ist in der vergangenheit
aber oft gesagt worden
sorry es tut mir leid ich kann ja als
bischof nicht zurücktreten das kann nur
der papst machen genau das ist so also
ein erzbischof asse könnte den ryck dem
papst den rücktritt anbieten würde ihnen
wahrscheinlich dann auch entsprechend
begründen
würde sagen hier ich habe in der
vergangenheit in anderer funktion
pflichtverletzungen begangen oder was er
auch mit anführen könnte das vertrauen
der gläubigen in mich als ihr bischof
ist so massiv erschüttert dass ich nicht
mehr bischof sein kann
im amt und dann entscheidet der papst
der papst hat in der vergangenheit in
solchen fällen sehr unterschiedlich
reagiert es gibt fälle in denen sehr
schnell reagiert wurde da geht es aber
meistens darum wenn bischöfe wirklich
entweder selber täter waren oder ihn
wirklich ganz groben fällen an
vertuschung und verschleppung von
aufarbeitung beteiligt waren in anderen
fällen war der papst sehr zögerlich und
hat gesagt jetzt warten wir erst mal ab
also jetzt lassen wir uns mal genau
dieses gutachten durchlesen und
vielleicht müssen wir aufgrund dieses
gutachtens dann auch noch mal weitere
untersuchungen anstrengen
also ich rechne nicht damit dass da
jetzt irgendwie in den nächsten wochen
irgendetwas in bezug auf die bischöfe
die jetzt auch genannt wurde erzbischof
käse oder weihbischof schwaderlapp in
seiner ehemaligen funktion als general
wk dass da jetzt sehr schnell etwas
passieren wird
es stellt sich automatisch die frage es
gibt hier zuschriften klaus jahn sind
schreibt die kirchen sitzen das problem
aus wie viele pädophile geistliche
straftäter wurden denn schon verurteilt
kann man das sagen
das ist ganz schwierig weil zum einen
sind die prozesse oft nicht öffentlich
man man bekommt es nicht mit die dinge
sind dezentral geführt also es gibt mir
ist nicht bekannt dass es irgendwo eine
statistik gibt jetzt auf vielleicht auf
ebene der bischofskonferenz oder
weltweit weil auch ganz oft gefragt wird
wie viele priester wurden denn schon aus
dem klerikerstand entlassen
und wenn wir das dann versuchen irgendwo
in rom bei der glaubenskongregation im
vatikan herauszubekommen
da werden dann so grobe zahlen genannt
da hört man dann durchaus mal dass das
auch eine vierstellige zahl ist auf die
weltkirche betrachtet aber aber mit den
zahlen hat man nicht jetzt schreibt
felix geber das gäbe es das über youtube
ist doch ein witz
die gehören alle angeklagt ist gehört
eine riesengroße untersuchung her die
der kirche auf die finger schaut und
zwar weltweit ich vermute felix dass
damit gemeint ist eine sozusagen
untersuchung einen blick von außen und
das ist ja eine frage die sich mehrere
stellen mag longuet higgins schreibt per
mail
warum wird der katholischen kirche das
recht zugestanden selbst zu ermitteln
und zu richten hier liegt eine
fehlinterpretation fehlinterpretation
des rechtsstaates vor die
staatsanwaltschaft muss in diesem fall
und in allen fällen von sexuellen
missbrauch ermittelt
nicht die kirche als verursachen kannst
du das noch mal einordnen professor
katja gesagt allein das gutachten ist ja
schon an die staatsanwaltschaft gegangen
und habe man muss ja auch noch mal
glasklar sagen dass dieses gutachten ja
jetzt nicht die missbrauchsfälle
untersucht hat sondern den umgang mit
den missbrauchsfällen aber da kannst du
das noch mal einordnen hier ist ja
verständlicherweise dieses gefühl muss
er nicht der staat drauf gucken ja ich
glaube man muss verschiedene dinge
unterscheiden zum einen ist natürlich
klar jeder fall jeder verdacht er auf
kommt der muss von kirchlichen stellen
an die staatsanwalt gemeldet werden und
dann muss die ermitteln
nun ist es in ganz vielen fällen so wir
haben das jetzt gerade auch gehört ein
großer teil der fälle ist vor 1975
passiert also das heißt die
staatsanwaltschaft hat oft gar keine
mittel mehr weil die feststellt das
vorgehen ist verjährt deshalb bräuchte
es neben dieser prüfung durch die
staatsanwaltschaft eigentlich etwas was
die betroffenen seit langer zeit fordern
nämlich eine unabhängige untersuchung
der missbrauchsfälle
also hier ist die politik in den letzten
zehn jahren meines erachtens auch etwas
zögerlich dass man sagt wir überlassen
das nicht den kirchen würde ja auch die
evangelische kirche betreffen zum
beispiel überlassen das nicht gegen
sondern wir setzen eine unabhängige
wahrheitskommission
untersuchungskommission ein wie es zum
beispiel in österreich passiert ist wir
sind ihr land passiert ist australien da
hat der staat jeweils gehandelt
und hat gesagt wir untersuchen das jetzt
und überlassen das nicht den kirchen in
deutschland geht man einen anderen weg
weil um es gab eine vereinbarung im
letzten jahr der bischofskonferenz der
deutschen mit dem unabhängigen
beauftragten der bundesregierung für
sexuellen missbrauch da wurden standards
vereinbart für eine unabhängige
aufarbeitung und mittlerweile kardinal
woelki hat am montag eine entsprechende
vereinbarung unterzeichnet und hat
gesagt jawohl wir werden nach diesen
maßgaben die mit dem staatlichen
vertreter ausgearbeitet wurden werden
wir jetzt auch eine unabhängige
aufarbeitung eine komplette sozusagen im
erzbistum köln staaten mittlerweile
haben glaube ich 16 der 27 bistümer
eine solcher zu einer solchen
aufarbeitung sich verpflichtet und
vereinbarungen mit herrn röhrig das ist
der chef dieser unabhängigen stelle der
bundesregierung vereinbart es bleibt
aber immer in regie der kirchen also da
ist auch das ist auch eine politische
entscheidung in deutschland die viele
nicht nachvollziehen können warum man
das nicht unabhängig macht die
bischofskonferenz der vorsitzende
bischof bätzing hat erst vor wenigen
wochen gesagt wir könnten uns auch so
eine unabhängige aufarbeitung durch eine
vom staat eingesetzte kommission oder
wie man das auch immer nennt vorstellen
aber nur wenn es nicht nur um die
katholische kirche geht sondern wenn
dann eben auch die evangelische kirche
wenn auch die sportverbände mit dabei
sind wenn wir sozusagen mehrere
institutionen anschauen dann ist er auch
nicht verschlossen dagegen er möchte
aber nicht dass man sagt okay wir machen
jetzt nur etwas und schauen nur auf die
katholische kirche
gregor stirn niemanden der über facebook
geschrieben hat er sagte es brauchte
weitere gutachten um objektiv beurteilen
zu können
jawohl da greifen sie im grunde genau
das gleiche auf was professor gehrke
gesagt hat das kann nicht das letzte
gutachten das kann nicht der letzte
schritt sein sondern nur einen baustein
du hast es ja auch gerade gesagt es muss
also auch von anderer seite oder aus
einer anderen perspektive weiter das
ganze betrachtet werde insofern richtig
doris peter schreibt über facebook ist
das nur ein problem der deutschen
kirchen oder greifen nur die deutschen
das problem auf da hast du gerade schon
gesagt die österreicher andere tun ist
auch und sogar in
einer anderen form in einem anderen
umgang genau das ist natürlich eine ein
problem das es in der gesamten welt
kirche gibt dass es in vielen ländern
gibt auch wenn über lange zeit viele
bischöfe gesagt haben na das ist ein
problem das gibt es in den
angelsächsischen sprachraum also
nordamerika großbritannien irland und in
zentraleuropa aber dem ist nicht so
pabst franziskus hat ja vor zwei jahren
mal einen sogenannten missbrauchs gipfel
zu einem missbrauchs gipfel alle
vorsitzenden der bischofskonferenzen
weltweit nach rom geladen um genau das
zu erreichen
man hat betroffene eingeladen die dann
da auch zeugnis gegeben haben ihr
schicksal erzählt haben vor sozusagen
der versammelten kirchenspitze aus der
ganzen welt um deutlich zu machen leute
das ist ein problem das in der gesamten
welt kirche besteht das wird
unterschiedlich konsequent angegangen
selbst sozusagen im land des papstes in
italien hat man sehr lange gebraucht im
vergleich zu deutschland wo man 2010 ja
dann durch die durch die
veröffentlichungen rund um das
canisius-kolleg und mit pater mertes
dann angefangen hat 2002 war es schon in
den usa da sieht man da haben auch die
deutschen bischöfe über acht jahre ist
es gab zwar erste richtlinien wie man
damit umgehen soll aber da hat man
eigentlich acht jahre ins land streichen
lassen
bis dann am canisius- kolleg zusammen
mit dem pater mertes sich einige
betroffene dann wirklich auch in die
öffentlichkeit gewagt haben jetzt immer
wieder zehn jahre weiter man kann das
mitbekommen so seit etwa einem jahr ist
ganz stark in polen auch diese
diskussion rund um das thema missbrauch
also man sieht es ist dass es nicht ein
problem das nur in deutschland im
deutschen sprachraum besteht das ist ein
problem weltweit das aber sehr
unterschiedlich konsequent angegangen
wird in dem sinn da muss man dann sagen
sind die deutschen weiter auch wenn auch
wenn die betroffenen schon recht haben
es geht zu langsam
es ist ein flickenteppich also ich hab
gerade in den letzten tagen mal wieder
gedacht wir bekommen rund um die
pandemie jetzt sage ich mal der
föderalismus in unserem staate und dann
auch die rolle die zb diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat da hab
ich mir jetzt gedacht dass er so ein
bisschen mitteln
das ist das ist die bischofskonferenz
ist wie die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
da sitzen sie zusammen und beschließen
etwas aber nachher ist jeder bischof
muss es dann erst mal in seinem eigenen
bistum umsetzen wenn er sagt ich mache
nicht mit dann macht da nicht mit
und dann kann der vorsitzende einmal wie
die kanzlerin lange versuchen irgendwie
und sagen mensch lasst uns doch in diese
richtung gehen wenn jemand nicht mitgeht
geht da nicht mit und so föderal sind
dann auch mittlerweile die dinge wenn
die auch wenn es um die aufarbeitung von
missbrauch geht jedes bistum macht in
handgestrickt nach ihrem nach ihrem
besten wissen und gewissen eine studie
und herr gerke hat es ja auch gesagt ist
liegen ja schon ein paar auf den tisch
die sind aber gar nicht vergleichbar und
und das soll übrigens genau dieses
prozedere verhindern von dem ich vorhin
sprach diese studien nach maßgabe der
regeln die man mit dem
missbrauchsbeauftragten der
bundesregierung ausgearbeitet hat die
sollen dann endlich auch mal
vergleichbar sein damit man sagen kann
das was er in mainz erforscht hat was
ihr in münchen in köln in hamburg in
berlin in aachen
jetzt kriegen wir mal ein vergleichbares
bild wir haben schon eine reihe von
studien aber die kriegt man gar nicht
zusammen weil die nach unter jeder jeder
untersuchende hat sich eigene maßstäbe
gesetzt so herr gerke ist gerade auch
geschildert hat er hat ja auch sehr
deutlich geschildert wenn man das
einfach mal mit dem weltlichen recht
vergleicht nicht dass also früher in den
60er jahren vielleicht jemand ein
überfall gemacht hat ich sage mal in
köln
und wenn der dann im auto über die a 3
nach frankfurt gefahren ist ist im
sicheren hessen dann hat die hessische
polizei sozusagen das nicht mitbekommen
was er da in köln angestellt hat und
einmal vielleicht auf der sicheren seite
wird man sagen gut das ist jahrzehnte
her
heute gibt es computer und abgleiche et
cetera und er hat gesagt das
fürchterliche ist sozusagen in der
katholischen kirche das ja auch über
jahre lang oftmals der priester der in
was ich was der einen in dem ein bistum
oder in seiner gemeinde etwas gemacht
hat dann versetzt worden ist ganz
woanders hin
und dann kann man wirklich sagen hat er
quasi gesagt aus den augen aus dem sinn
das ist ja auch so ein bisschen der
punkt wenn das eine bistum nicht weiß
was das andere macht wenn es da nicht
miteinander
kommunikation gibt dann hilft das ja
sozusagen den tätern nicht den opfern
genau also das ist mit sicherheit ein
großes problem dass für viele jahrzehnte
gilt was ich jetzt bei herrn gehrke im
moment noch nicht raus gehört habe ist
so ein bisschen die frage hat sich das
denn in den letzten sagen wir mal fünf
sechs sieben jahren hat sich das
verändert weil das ist noch mal was ganz
entscheidend dass auch bei der studie
die ich erwähnt habe die ende 2018
vorgestellt wurde
es ist immer die frage okay der lange
zeitraum in dem fall war es jetzt ab
1975 wurde begonnen bis 2018 gibt es
denn eine veränderung im umgang mit
missbrauchsfällen kann man die
feststellen oder nicht wenn man die
feststellen kann und kann sagen okay in
den letzten sechs sieben jahren wurde es
anders gehandhabt da gab es zum beispiel
dann auch bei grenzüberschreitendem
versetzen von priestern
da gab es informationen da wurde enger
zusammengearbeitet wurde nachgefragt
dann kann man zumindest sagen okay man
stellt fest dass sich die dinge
verändern würde aber jetzt professor
gehrke zu dem ergebnis kommen das ist de
facto bis 2018 unverändert gewesen dann
wäre das natürlich in der tat verheerend
und vernichten da muss man nochmal genau
in das gutachten jetzt rein schauen weil
ich habe schon den eindruck was ich so
aus einzelnen bistümern see und was man
mitbekommt dass sich an vielen stellen
das bewusstsein in den letzten jahren
klar verändert hat dass man ganz gezielt
nachfragt nochmal auch rückwirkend und
sagt sag mal ihr habt uns da vor zehn
jahren den fahrer so geschickt rückt mal
was war denn da los
wieso habt ihr den über eure grenzen
hinweg zu uns versetzt oder uns dann
angeboten
also da ist an vielen stellen glaube ich
schon ein bewusstseinswandel da aber man
muss genau noch mal hinschauen ob auch
geärgert dass jetzt fest stellt in
seinem gutachten oder nicht
jetzt will ich das aufgreifen was du so
angedeutet hat die spannung wächst ja
persönlich in das gutachten
reinzuschauen wir haben jetzt eine
stunde von professor werner
informationen gehört in der pk werden
derzeit noch weiter fragen gestellt
an den gutachter professor gehrke und
seine kollegin die sehen wir da beide
und jetzt soll das gutachten an
bischof woelki den kardinal in köln
überreicht werden da wollen wir dann
gleich wieder live drauf gehen weil es
dann im anschluss auch das statement des
kardinals geben soll hören wir einfach
mal rein wenn das gutachten jetzt
überreicht wird
gutachten das er jetzt in den händen
hält in auftrag gegeben hat sagt einmal
für kameras im anzug professor gehrke
den wir zugehört haben und seine
kollegin frau dr kerstin stirner die
beide zusammen
ja ich würde mal sagen doch sehr
nachvollziehbar anschaulich die methode
erklärt haben die prinzipien wie sie
eine ampel geschaltet haben die für ihn
cardenal berggruen ist aber wir sind
gespannt was er jetzt sagt denn es sind
doch brisante dinge im gutachten und in
den statements der juristen gewesen
hören wir jetzt dem erzbischof zu ein
statement von kardinal woelki der
kardinal sie haben das wort
entschuldigung ich habe das nicht so
richtig wahrgenommen
so rückt der stürmer herr professor
gehrke danke ich habe diesen tag auf der
einen seite herbeigesehnt und daraufhin
gelebt seit langem wie sie sich das
vorstellen können und ich habe diesen
tag wie sich das wahrscheinlich ebenso
vorstellen können und nachempfinden nun
nachvollziehen können
gefürchtet wie nichts anderes
wir wissen bereits seit jahren dass sich
geistliche schuldig gemacht haben
sie haben sich schuldig gemacht indem
sie das in sie gesetzte vertrauen
missbraucht und ihnen anvertrauten
menschen gewalt zugefügt haben
und das in vielen fällen ohne dafür
bestraft zu werden und umso schlimmer
ohne dass die von dieser gewalt
betroffenen im letzten wirklich ernst
genommen wurden geschweige denn dass sie
geschützt wurden
das ist vertuschung heute haben wir alle
die die enttäuschende bestätigung
erfahren was dieses wort bedeutet
höchste verantwortungsträger haben diese
taten
nicht nach oben gemeldet und sie haben
damit untersuchungen augenscheinlich
untersuchungen und strafverfahren
verhindert sie haben nicht sanktioniert
sondern verzögert oder den schutz der
betroffenen nicht beachtet höchste
verantwortungsträger auch meine
vorgänger haben sich vielfach klar
schuldig gemacht nichts geahnt
das ist seit heute nicht mehr möglich
und nicht mehr denkbar
die besondere bedeutung der priester
wird klar in einem zentralen fakt den
sie genannt haben verlobter spinner
nämlich schwere pflichtverletzungen gab
es eigentlich nur in den fällen bei
denen geistliche täter waren nicht
jedoch bei laien
dort wurde augenscheinlich immer schnell
und konsequent entschieden gehandelt und
das spricht bände
und ich muss sagen das berührt mich und
beschämt mich auch zutiefst
denn ich bin überzeugt handeln muss auch
für kleriker konsequenzen haben taten
wiegen schwerer als worte und daher
möchte ich auch aus der situation dieser
stunde heraus und auch auf der grundlage
dessen was ich hier gerade gehört habe
die gerade genannten weihbischof
schwaderlapp und herrn offizial
assenmacher mit sofortiger wirkung
vorläufig von ihren aufgaben entbinden
damit gebe ich die möglichkeit zur
reflexion und zum offenen gespräch
ich werde das gutachten jetzt in den
nächsten tagen erst einmal selber lesen
müssen
und weitere konsequenzen dann daraus
ableiten
nicht für alle hier genannten bin ich
zuständig bei einem erzbischof und einem
weihbischof muss der heilige stuhl
entscheiden und deshalb werde ich noch
heute das gutachten nach rom weiter
leiten
eine erste zusage ist damit eingelöst
aufdecken was war und was ist
vertuschung aufklären und die namen von
verantwortlichen zu nennen
das ist nur ein erster schritt über die
weiteren unmittelbaren konsequenzen
personell und organisatorisch werden
general ik hofmann und ich sie dann am
kommenden dienstag hier an gleicher
stelle informieren
vielen dank vielen dank herr kardinal
er bringt man hensel da darf ich sie ja
soweit der erzbischof in seinem
statement die erste reaktion das waren
deutliche worte von kardinal woelki über
die wir jetzt gemeinsam sprechen wollen
jürgen erbacher vielleicht noch ganz
kurz dahinter auch das gutachten an
einen vertreter des betroffenen beirats
des erzbistums köln überreicht der wird
dann wenn ich es richtig weiß auch
gleich im anschluss noch ein paar worte
sozusagen auch innerhalb dieser
pressekonferenz an alle richten danach
das hatten wir ja schon angedeutet
über das gutachten gesprochen im
betroffenen beirat bevor wir es dann
alle lesen können
ja und wir wollen erstmal über das
statement von kardinal woelki sprechen
du irgendwas auch noch mal erklären wie
es weitergeht wir hören mal ganz kurz
rein was der sprecher des betroffenen
rat sagt
herr kardinal wirklich ich bin
überrascht über dieses erste über die
erste konsequenz die siege worte
ausgesprochen haben meine persönliche
meinung ist ich habe nichts anderes
erwartet von ihnen da ist sie einer
anderen stelle schon einmal erlebt haben
wo sie ganz gerade nach vorne gegangen
sind
meine damen und herren für den
betroffenen beirates erzbistum köln köln
möchte auch ich einige kurze worte an
sie richten aufs am heutigen tag liegt
das gutachten zum umgang mit sexuellen
missbrauch im erzbistum köln vor
auf diesem wichtigen schritt der
aufklärung mussten wir lange
beziehungsweise zu lange warten
aber ich bin heute froh dass zumindest
dieses versprechen gehalten worden ist
ich bin dankbar dafür dass der
betroffene beirat bei der erstellung des
gutachtens teilweise beteiligt war
wer die mitglieder des betroffenen
beirates haben die pressekonferenz in
einem separaten raum verfolgt wir werden
jetzt mit einem vertreter der kanzlei
unsere fragen zu der präsentation
besprechen und klären um über unsere
sichtweise auf das gutachten und die
konsequente mit der bistumsleitung zu
reden haben wir bereits im vorfeld
unserer nächsten sitzung für die
kommende woche terminiert danach wird
der betroffenen beirat eine
stellungsnahme abgeben
in eigener sache möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich an den bundespräsidenten
bedanken der matthias katsch zum
bundesverdienstkreuz geehrt hat er ist
der vierte in unserer runde der wegen
der aufklärung
von misshandlungen an kindern geehrt
worden vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
dann verbringt man handle so weit ein
vertreter des betroffenen beirats im
erzbistum köln der eben auf das
gutachten und auch auf die worte von
erzbischof kardinal woelki reagiert hat
wir werden gleich auch mit einem
betroffenen mit dem wir schon gesprochen
haben mit patrick bauer drüber sprechen
der von der pressekonferenz wenn sie
vorbei ist wieder zu unserem schaltpunkt
kommt das heißt wir werden auf jeden
fall auch mit jemandem sprechen der
sexuellen missbrauch erlebt hat vor
vielen jahren der uns ja schon
geschildert hat dass ihn das bis heute
verfolgt und natürlich haben wir die
brennende frage wie es ihm geht wenn er
diese pressekonferenz verfolgt hat und
diese informationen erfahren hat
kardinal berkeley hat gesagt ich habe
diesen tag herbeigesehnt ich habe diesen
tag gefürchtet furcht vor ihm gehabt wir
wissen dass geistliche schulde sich
schuldig gemacht haben ohne dafür
bestraft zu werden ohne dass die
betroffenen ernst genommen worden sind
und noch schlimmer ohne dass sie
geschützt worden sind das ist
vertuschung so klar hat er es gesagt
heute die enttäuschende bestätigung dass
was das was das wort vertuschung heißt
höchste verantwortungsträger auch meine
vorgänger haben sich schuldig gemacht
und wir haben es eben mitbekommen dass
er direkt konsequenzen erste
konsequenzen gezogen hat weil bischof
schwaderlapp und generalvikar
assenmacher hat er mit sofortiger
wirkung von den aufgaben entbunden
jürgen überraschen die ich diese klaren
worte war das zu erwarten oder würdest
du sagen ja da hat der kardinal
sozusagen drei versprechen die er
genannt hat aufdecken was war was ist
vertuschung aufdecken und namen von
verantwortlichen nennen
dass er diese versprechen sozusagen
erfüllt hat er hat das erfüllt was er
angekündigt hat er hat gesagt er möchte
konsequenzen ziehen sobald
verantwortliche benannt sind ich muss
gestehen ich hatte eher damit gerechnet
das hat das am nächsten dienstag macht
wenn er dieses gutachten dann auch
nochmal genauer gesichtet hat und alles
das was wir gehört dass wir alle
zusammen so gewesen sein ein passgenau
für ihn war das klar er vertraut auf das
sozusagen die expertise der kanzlei und
wenn die sagt wir haben bei weihbischof
schwaderlapp entsprechend
pflichtverletzungen vorliegen
wir haben bei herrn assenmacher dem
obersten kirchen richter sozusagen des
erzbistums köln auch unklarheiten dann
hat er sofort die konsequenzen gezogen
er hat sie ja sage ich mal jetzt von
ihren aufgaben entbunden er hat ja auch
gesagt das ist eine phase des gesprächs
und der reflexion von daher muss man
schauen kann durchaus sein dass sie auch
beide wieder in ihren aufgabenbereich
zurückkommen aber für den moment sind
sie sozusagen entbunden weil er ja von
anfang an gesagt hat ich möchte klar
zeigen dass ich dann auch handel und ich
glaube das war auch notwendig er stand
ja schon enorm unter druck
und alle haben natürlich genau auch
drauf geschaut wie wird er reagieren was
wird er sagen du hast die worte noch mal
zitiert es ist auch noch mal sehr klar
und deutlich auch benannt seine
vorgänger kardinal meisner dass er ist
auch für für kardinal woelki eine eine
wichtige person in seiner biografie und
dann auch hier so klar ohne dass er
jetzt den namen direkt genannt hat aber
trotzdem zu sagen meine vorgänger haben
hier ganz klar fehler gemacht das ist
glaube ich schon etwas was ihm auch
nicht leicht fällt
auch weihbischof schwaderlapp kennt er
seit langer zeit aber für ihn ist klar
unabhängig von rang und namen
ich will und muss jetzt auch handeln man
muss wir haben anfang unseres
livestreams jahr in einem kompakten
beitrag die situation einfach mal
angeschaut und da war auch der o-ton
eine aussage von kardinal woelki drinnen
die ja für kritik gesorgt hat er hat in
der christmette oder kurz danach in
einer messe gesagt was sie an der kritik
hat er zu den gläubigen in der kirche
gesagt was sie an der kritik darüber und
insbesondere auch an der kritik an
meiner person ertragen mussten für all
das bitte ich sie um verzeihung da haben
viele aufgeschrieben haben gesagt das
ist ja ein
feiern anstatt sich bei opfern zu
entschuldigen als zu sagen ich nenne
namen ich kläre auf entschuldigt er sich
sozusagen für naja die unangenehme
diskussion
würdest du sagen das sind andere ort
worte wenn er eben heute sagt das
berührt mich zutiefst was er jetzt
gehört hat die klaren beweise beispiele
von vertuschung handeln muss auch für
kleriker konsequenzen haben und dann hat
er eine sekunde danach eben 2 ja sag ich
mal kollegen mit sofortiger wirkung von
den aufgaben entbunden ist das heute
dann doch eine andere art die werke
spricht es ist mit sicherheit eine
andere art allerdings hat er ja heute
eine grüne ampel bekommen von daher sage
ich mal er sagt ja auch gesagt er hat
diesen tag gefürchtet wie nichts anderes
es war ja auch für ihn nicht ganz klar
um jetzt in diesem system zu bleiben der
von professor gerke welche farbe wird er
bekommen und ich glaube vor dem
hintergrund sind auch viele aussagen
auch in den letzten monaten zu sehen
weihnachten da war gerade kurz vor
weihnachten einen fall auf gekloppt wo
man auch ihm vorwarf nicht richtig
gehandelt zu haben auch in seiner zeit
in köln als erzbischof
da hatte er sich zwar kurz vor
weihnachten nach oben gewendet aber da
war noch keine reaktion aus rom da also
die situation ist natürlich jetzt eine
völlig andere für ihn
ich bezweifle nicht dass er unabhängig
von der farbe die er heute bekommen
hätte auch klar und konsequent so etwas
gesagt hätte und ich möchte nicht
ausschließen so wie wir es jetzt im fall
von weihbischof schwaderlapp und dem
obersten kirchen richter erlebt haben
wenn er heute ein rot bekommen hätte
in den worten oder wie wir ihn jetzt
gerade eben erlebt haben wäre es
konsequent gewesen zu sagen ich schicke
heute nicht nur den bericht nach rom
sondern ich schicke da noch ein brief
mit deutlichen worten an den papst und
die zuständigen im vatikan für die
bischöfe und kardinäle nach rom also
dass nach dem auftritt gerade eben würde
ich das nicht ausschließen aber er ist
nun mal im moment mit grünen andere
haben sozusagen rot bekommen in diesem
ampelsystem
sie haben das alle mit verfolgt unter
anderem nicht nur der verstorbene
erzbischof meisner da kann man nichts
machen sondern auch erzbischof
hefner und der erzbischof von hamburg
asse für seine verfehlungen in seiner
amtszeit in köln
und das ist ja nun das interessante du
hast es vorher erklärt da kann kardinal
meister nicht sagen ich entbinde euch
ich entlasse euch das kann nur durch rom
durch den papst passieren insofern hat
es eine gewisse brisanz also nach dem
motto muss jetzt ein erzbischof heese in
hamburg doch ein bisschen zittern wenn
dieses gutachten jetzt per post stempel
richtung vatikan nach oben geht
rom wird sich das anschauen ganz klar
und wird genau gucken welche
pflichtverletzungen sind das wiwi schwer
wie schwerwiegend die dann wird mit
sicherheit auch der erzbischof sie die
gelegenheit haben sich entsprechend dann
auch zu äußern auch im gespräch mit rom
und dann wird man schauen
kardinal woelki hat ja in der tat gesagt
sobald es um bischöfe geht gerade gerade
eben einem kurzen statement
sobald es um bischöfe geht bin ich nicht
der handelnde das muss man jetzt sehen
man muss man muss rein schauen in das
gutachten erzbischof these hat sich ja
in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
auch mehrfach zu vorwürfen geäußert aus
dem ersten gutachten wurden ja einzelne
teile auch so ein bisschen genau sind so
ein bisschen durchgesickert und da hat
er ja schon immer wieder auch gesagt
dass er aus seiner sicht da richtig
gehandelt hat
jetzt muss man mal schauen jetzt steht
ja hier sozusagen auch ein bisschen
aussage gegen aussage wenn professor
gehrke und sein team sagen hier liegen
pflichtverletzungen vor
der erzbischof sich bisher da eher
zurückhaltend auch in diese richtung
geäußert hat
muss man jetzt sehen was die nächsten
tage und wochen bringen da passt ein
kommentar von charlie vechte den wir
bekommen haben oder jemanden in schutz
zu nehmen es wurde aber auch in der
schulung pardon und jörg huthmann ich
bin eine zahl desto tief gerutscht
jörg huthmann schreibt scheinheiliger so
sein vorwurf geht es nicht verstorbene
werden schuldig gesprochen er meint
damit erzbischof meisner den
verstorbenen erzbischof lebende werden
verschonen da sind wir genau natürlich
bei den punkt wir haben lebende die hier
glasklar die rote karte bekommen haben
und du hast es gerade gesagt er ist
bischof jesus sieht ist auch ein
bisschen nach bisherigen statements
nicht ein also ist das durchaus jetzt
spannend zu beobachten was sich jetzt
weiter daraus entwickeln wird einerseits
was nächste woche dienstag dann kardinal
meister noch mal sagen wird und welche
partei wirklich sagen wird und was eben
auch aus rom kommen wird da muss man
natürlich einen 800 seiten starkes
gutachten auch erst einmal in ruhe lesen
dann hier noch ein kommentar typisch
katholische kirche man kauft sich seine
eigene unschuld und den ablass die in
scheinheilig muss man denn so sein um so
aufzutreten kardinal wörtlich hat das
andere gutachten ja schon mal nicht
veröffentlicht also freut er sich jetzt
seine unschuld präsentieren zu dürfen
du hast das jetzt schon ein bisschen
gesagt na ja ja ich meine wir werden
sehen nächste woche ab donnerstag liegt
auch das erste gutachten aus und dann
werden natürlich die journalisten
kollegen wir werden natürlich schauen
was steht denn in dem ersten gutachten
zu kardinal woelki drin man hat gehört
professor gerke hat ja erzählt dass ein
mitarbeiter der münchner kanzlei schon
letztes jahr im frühjahr im bischofshaus
angerufen hat in köln und gesagt hat
keine sorge der erzbischof ist ist da
haben wir keine verletzungen gefunden
also von daher stimmen beide gutachten
anscheinend in bezug auf die person
kardinal woelki überein
also die münchner haben
wie gesagt ich habe jetzt auch nichts
gefunden gerke hat ja immer noch mal
alle akten die ihm zur verfügung
gestellt wurden auch untersucht von
daher scheinen die beiden so zu einer
identischen zu einer identischen zu
einem identischen ergebnis gekommen zu
sein dass es immer ein geschmäckle hat
das hatten wir vorher schon besprochen
man muss ja normal auftraggeber ist das
hängt ein bisschen daran dass wir in
deutschland eben nicht eine herangehen
haben wo die politik sagt wir wollen das
unabhängig von außen bearbeiten und dann
macht die kirche ist selber zwar in
absprache mit dem bundesbeauftragten für
für missbrauch aber so ist die situation
in deutschland
da muss ich ja auch noch mal noch mal
sagen professor berger hatte in der
pressekonferenz
wer vielleicht nicht alle so in
erinnerung hat oder nicht hat
mitverfolgen können dann auch noch mal
zur erinnerung hat glasteil gesagt ich
das ist nur ein element er hat mehrfach
betont dass sein gutachten sogar
ausführlicher ist also bei gleicher
schriftgröße und gleichen zeilenabstand
ungefähr doppelt so groß ich habe sie
geschrieben ist wie das aus münchen als
er wollte damit deutlich machen es ist
nicht weniger als was die münchner
kollegen herausgefunden haben oder
zusammengetragen haben sondern sie haben
sich wirklich mühe gegeben hat aber auch
mehrfach in der pressekonferenz in den
erklärungen zu seinem gutachten
unterstrichen dass das auch nicht alles
möglicherweise nicht alles ist dass das
so zu sagen ja nur auf der basis ist der
akten die man zur verfügung gestellt
bekommen hat und wenn man von ihm und
seiner kollegin gehört hat dass akten
geschreddert worden sind nicht
auffindbar sind
unsauber schlampig geführt worden sind
dann verstehen wir ja auch nur auf der
basis dieser bescheidenen daten ist das
rausgekommen und vielleicht gibt es noch
einiges mehr da kann man natürlich jetzt
nicht die hand für ihn ins feuer legen
wie ohlmann 86 schreibt über youtube mal
ein kommentar respekt das hätte ich von
woelki so jetzt nicht erwartet und wir
wollen einfach noch mal ganz kurz einen
auszug aus seinem statement höher
wir wissen bereits seit jahren dass sich
geistliche schuldig gemacht haben
sie haben sie schuldig gemacht indem sie
das in sie gesetzte
frauen missbraucht und ihnen
anvertrauten menschen gewalt zugefügt
haben
und das in vielen fällen ohne dafür
bestraft zu werden und umso schlimmer
ohne dass die von dieser gewalt
betroffenen im letzten wirklich ernst
genommen wurden geschweige denn dass sie
geschützt wurden
das ist vertuschung taten wiegen
schwerer als worte und daher möchte ich
auch aus der situation dieser stunde
heraus und auch auf der grundlage dessen
was ich hier gerade gehört habe die
gerade genannten weihbischof
schwaderlapp und herrn offizial
assenmacher mit sofortiger wirkung
vorläufig von ihren aufgaben entbinden
ja das war das statement ein auszug von
kardinal woelki jürgen das sind klare
worte
die haben wir bisher kann man da sagen
so auch noch nicht gehört
das stimmt das ist eine große eine große
forderung der betroffenen es gab ja
schon vereinzelt gab es schon vereinzelt
studien gutachten die vorgestellt wurden
im bistum limburg im bistum trier im
erzbistum berlin auch an anderen stellen
und die betroffenen haben immer gesagt
es ist jetzt schön die jeweiligen
bischöfe haben dann auch oft
arbeitsgruppen eingerichtet kommissionen
die die empfehlungen umsetzen sollen
aber wo sind die personellen
konsequenzen
wo wird auch verantwortung übernommen
also hier unterscheidet sich jetzt schon
das was wir gerade eben erlebt haben in
köln von anderen bistümern das muss man
ganz klar sagen
entscheidend wird jetzt sein wie wird in
zukunft damit umgegangen wir haben hier
von herrn professor gehrke gehört auch
für das erzbistum köln steht eine
grundsätzliche aufarbeitung der
missbrauchsfälle noch an
er hatte einen ganz speziellen auftrag
da ging es vor allen dingen auch darum
diese verantwortlichkeiten diese auch
die frage nach dem system zu beantworten
aber wenn jetzt die betroffenen
erzbistum köln genau wissen wollen oder
auch die öffentlichkeit wie viele fälle
gab es und wie sieht es damit aus da
wird das jetzt wieder ein weiteres
gutachten brauchen und da muss man jetzt
schauen der kardinal hat vorgestern sich
dazu darauf verpflichtet in einer
gemeinsamen erklärung auch mit dem
bundesbeauftragten herrn röhrig für den
sexuellen für den sexuellen missbrauch
und die aufarbeitung und das wird man
jetzt sehen wie konsequent der jetzt
auch das dann angeht
jetzt bleibt es ja spannend du hast es
deutlich gemacht das ist ein erster
schritt
auch der gutachter professor gerke hat
gesagt das ist nur ein baustein also man
kann jetzt nicht sagen mit dem gutachten
ist die sache jetzt abgeschlossen
der kardinal hat ja auch versprochen du
hast es schon erwähnt wenn dieses
gutachten von gehrke dieses zweite neue
gutachten veröffentlicht ist also ab
heute dann könne man auch in das erste
rein schauen dann kann man das ganze
vergleichen und das erzbistum köln
gewährt einsicht am 25
jürgen wirst du nach köln düsen und
sagen ich gucke mir beides anja
natürlich möchte man jetzt wissen weil
zum einen will man ja auch mal selber
sehen was sind denn jetzt wirklich die
unterschiede wo ist das problem dass wir
jetzt ein jahr lang hier extremst ach ja
warten mussten aber das ist auch diese
ganzen diskussionen gab für die
betroffenen
herr brinkmann es hensel da hat es ja
gesagt diese veröffentlichung kommt zu
spät also das will man ja genau wissen
was ist jetzt genau der unterschied und
an anderen stellen wie man natürlich
auch schauen wo gibt es differenzen
werden da vielleicht noch andere
personen genannt in dem ersten gutachten
das wird mit sicherheit werden daher
sage ich mal wird es eine schlange geben
derer die da hinein schauen wollen um
dann eben auch genau zu schauen war es
das wert so lange warten zu müssen
insofern wird es noch spannend werden du
wirst uns sozusagen
für uns auf dem laufenden halten aber
die frage an dich
man muss sich vor augen halten
journalisten als das erste gutachten
also vor einem jahr
der münchner kanzlei fertiggestellt
worden war noch nicht veröffentlicht war
da durften journalisten schon mal
einsicht bekommen und das bedeutet aber
eben einsicht das muss sie jetzt auch
noch mal erklären das heißt ja nicht
dass sie nur kopie bekommen haben und
das dann veröffentlichen konnten sondern
das heißt das sind acht journalisten
hingegangen
genau das ist jetzt das einmal bei dem
es gibt den unterschied was jetzt mit
dem gehrke gutachten passiert heute
mittag das kann man im wird ins internet
gestellt das kann jeder und jede lesen
das war eigentlich auch mit dem ersten
gutachten gedacht dann gab es ja die
juristischen probleme dass experten
sagten sowie das gutachten hier verfasst
ist kann man kann man das nicht
veröffentlichen da werden
persönlichkeitsrechte verletzt und
deshalb wird auch dieses erste gutachten
weiterhin nicht veröffentlicht aber wenn
man einsicht nimmt und wäre dann der
nächste woche hingehen wir können das
dann durch lesen wir dürfen nicht
fotografieren oder filmen
wir dürfen uns aber notizen machen das
ist eine einsichtnahme damit werden
offensichtlich ich bin jetzt nicht so
der jurist experte juristische experte
aber damit sind diese
persönlichkeitsrechte wohl weiter
gewahrt und damit kann man eben diese
einsicht gewähren was jetzt das problem
war als man acht journalisten dieses
erste gutachten schon einmal zeigen
wollte war dass man sie zur
verschwiegenheit verpflichten wollte
also nächste woche wenn ich da hingehe
und schreibe mir dann aus dem ersten
gutachten bestimmte dinge ab dann kann
ich das hinterher auch veröffentlichen
also dann wirst du uns zum beispiel das
zählen können ob in dem ersten gutachten
tatsächlich sage ich mal namen von
sekretärin genannt worden sind wo man
sagen würde nach rechtlichen
gesichtspunkten genau wie das ist
richtig die hat man jetzt namen nicht
genannt hat weil sie nicht personen im
öffentlichen leben so zu sehen genau
also das müsste man dann so zumindest
bisher die ankündigung das müsste man
dann machen können nächste woche
und als es diese erste journalistin
geschichte gab hätten die kolleginnen
und kollegen hätte man hinterher nicht
sagen können sondern man hätte sozusagen
für sich für den eigenen so für die
eigene einordnung der ganzen
angelegenheit hätte man
einmal wäre es gut und wichtig gewesen
aber natürlich lassen wir journalisten
uns da auch nicht sein wenn ich so ein
gutachten anschaut dann möchte ich auch
darüber sprechen können und deshalb
haben sich dann auch die kollegen und
haben auch gesagt nee also wir
unterschreiben hier keine
verschwiegenheitserklärung wenn wir das
einsäen dann wollen wir auch darüber
sprechen deshalb ist dieser termin
geplatzt weil journalisten gesagt haben
nein das ja machen wenn ich mit ihr als
sie vor ort damit konfrontiert wurden
jetzt hier zu unterschreiben dass sie
sich zur verschwiegenheit verpflichtet
johannes wilm röhrig dieser der
unabhängige beauftragte der
bundesregierung hat vorweg vor wochen
schon mal gesagt in einem zeit
-interview alles rund um das erste von
woelki beauftragte gutachten ist eine
maximale kommunikationskatastrophe
würdest du sagen die katastrophe wird
jetzt ein bisschen bereinigt die wogen
ein bisschen geglättet mit diesem
gutachten und auch mit dem auftreten von
woelki also ob die wogen schon wirklich
geglättet sind das muss man nochmal
sehen klar er hat jetzt hier sag ich mal
erste taten folgen lassen
aber gut das ist ein erster schritt das
entscheidende wird sein was passiert in
den nächsten wochen was wird da auch am
nächsten dienstag vorstellen also wenn
es bei diesen zwei personalien bleibt
ich sage jetzt mal die vorübergehend zu
beurlauben
dann dann ist dann ist da wenig gewonnen
mir scheint aber schon mit diesem
gutachten sei schon einiges neues auf
den tisch zu legen wo man jetzt auch
noch mal klar sind ja auch noch ein paar
andere lebende benannt in diesem
gutachten da wird man auch schauen
müssen wie reagieren die wie geht man
mit denen um
von daher haben wir hier schon eine neue
qualität dass mehr bleibt stürmisch auch
für den kardinal
das kann ja jetzt nicht mit so einem mit
so einem mit seinem ersten mit seiner
ersten schnellen reaktion sofort wieder
in eine ruhige see verwandeln weil
natürlich auch zu recht die betroffenen
weitere konsequenzen fordern werden
und vor allen dingen auch mehr
transparenz das ist ein problem
an vielen stellen beim thema
aufarbeitung von missbrauch
wie transparenz sind verfahren wie
transparent sind eben vorgänge in diesem
kontext du sagst es gerade das meer
bleibt stürmisch für kardinal woelki es
ist völlig klar
du gehst ja hin nach köln und schaust
und vergleicht wir werden also noch
viele dinge erfahren aber wir haben es
auch schon gesagt jugend du hast du
schon gesagt er hat mit sicherheit
durchgeatmet schon vor einem jahr als
ihm von der münchner kanzlei die das
erste gutachten erstellt hat sozusagen
gesteckt wurden reg dich nicht auf
beziehungsweise atmet tief durch wir
haben gegen dich nichts gefunden
jetzt sind wir alle gespannt gewesen wie
das zweite gutachten aussieht und jetzt
haben wir von dem zweiten gutachter
gehrke eine einschätzung bekommen ob er
denn etwas anderes herausgefunden hat
über den kardinal wenn es verfehlungen
gegeben hat bei dem vorgänger erzbischof
meisner erzbischof höffner dann ist
natürlich auch die spannende frage wie
sieht es denn mit kardinal woelki aus
und das hat professor jacke der
gutachter vor anderthalb stunden gesagt
hinsichtlich erzbischof woelki konnten
wir keine pflichtverletzung erkennen
wenn einige theologen oder journalisten
in den vergangenen wochen dies ohne
kenntnis der akten und ohne befragung
von herrn woelki und anderen beteiligten
anders sehen als wir ist das ihr gutes
recht
es scheint dabei allerdings etwa in
vergessenheit zu geraten dass wir nicht
rückwirkend recht anwenden können
insbesondere nicht die empfehlung aus
dem vademecum aus 2020 für einen vorgang
aus 2011 oder 2015 zugrunde liegen
können wir legen mit unserer wertung die
wird sich leicht gemacht haben den
medial wäre es für uns am einfachsten
gewesen herr wirkliche zum schafott zu
führen
aber wir liegen mit dieser wertung nicht
nur auf linie mit dem heiligen stuhl
sondern über es auch mit den münchner
kollegen allerdings mit einem kleinen
unterschied
ein kollege aus der münchner kanzlei
hatte die referenten des kardinals
bereits im vergangenen frühjahr darüber
informiert dass dem kardinal nichts tue
und er sich keine sorgen machen brauchen
das ist mir doch im blick auf die
berichterstattung der vergangenen monate
wichtig auch wenn ich da das räume ich
ein die rolle des gutachters kurz
verlassen hätte der kardinal wirklich
etwas bezüglich seiner eigenen person zu
vertuschen gehabt hätte er das münchner
gutachten durchwinken können ein
rechtsstaat riskieren können
und hätte persönlich seine ruhe gehabt
ja und diese worte des gutachters von
professor gehrke auch das statement
natürlich von kardinal woelki hat
gespannt patrick bauer verfolgt der uns
jetzt wieder zugeschaltet ist ganz
herzlichen dank dass ihr aus gesprintet
sind jetzt aus der pressekonferenz und
wieder mit uns reden können ja was sagen
sie zu dieser pressekonferenz zu den
ergebnissen des gutachtens und natürlich
auch zu den worten zu dem statement des
kardinals also als allererstes muss ich
natürlich sagen kann ja welchen hat in
einem punkt wort gehalten er hat einen
gutachten veröffentlicht in dem namen
genannt worden sind in dem fakten
genannt worden sind in dem die
systemischen fehler aufgedeckt werden
das ist das erste das zweite ist
natürlich war mit ich worüber ich
wirklich überrascht bin ist dass er
bereits heute prälat assenmacher und
auch weihbischof schwaderlapp
suspendiert hat vorübergehend
suspendiert hat damit habe ich nicht
gerechnet
diese deutlichkeit hat mich überrascht
was mir fehlt was mir absolut fehlt ist
der hinweis darauf dass diese männer
sich bereits hätten vorher für ihr zu
ihrer schuld bekennen können dass sie es
erst schwarz auf weiß brauchten um
selbst einzugestehen was sie falsch
gemacht haben das ist das erste
das zweite ist was auch fehlt ist eine
moralische und ethische bewertung
es gibt einfach dinge die gehören sich
nicht dafür brauche ich kein recht dafür
brauche ich keinen text das weiß ich aus
dem leben heraus und wenn diese männer
nicht begriffen haben dass der schutz
eines kindes vor den schutz eines
mitbruders oder der institution geht
dann tut es mir schrecklich leid und
dann finde ich das ganze ehrlich gesagt
erbärmlich erbärmlich finde ich übrigens
auch und das hat professor gehrke
mehrfach gesagt das ist eine
überforderung gab
das ist ein nicht wissen gab auf eine
position gestellt auf die man nicht
vorbereitet war
entschuldigung das geht nicht das kann
nicht sein
wenn ich in die position eines
generalvikars eines
personalchefs gehe muss ich mich vorher
darauf vorbereiten und das ist grobe
fahrlässigkeit anders kann man das nicht
nennen
professor gerke hat ja auch sehr klar ja
als kritik formuliert es ging wohl mehr
darum also statt und die opfer in den
vordergrund zu stellen
den betroffenen zu helfen aufklärung zu
schaffen
eben genau diese fünf punkte die ja
sozusagen pflicht wären dinge zur
anzeige zu bringen zu sanktionieren
weitere taten zu verhindern stand wohl
im vordergrund an erster stelle
reputationsschäden zu vermeiden und den
täter im system zu lassen
haben sie da genügt ja natürlich
natürlich also das ist ja das was ich
eben gesagt habe und das ist das womit
wir betroffene immer leben müssen oder
mussten bis heute zumindest das ganz
klar war hier wird der schutz der
institution über den schutz des kindes
gestellt
und das tut mir gut das ist das was ich
mit befriedung am anfang sagte vor der
pressekonferenz meinte das hilft
tatsächlich so etwas zu benennen
das hilft dazu dass wir betroffene zu
einer befriedung kommen befriedigung
werden wir wahrscheinlich nie erhalten
und auch kann nicht ausreichend
entschädigung aber zumindest der punkt
dass diese dinge endlich benannt sind
dass kirche selbst dazu jetzt stehen
muss wobei ich nach wie vor immer wieder
sagen kann da hätte man auch von alleine
drauf kommen können
dazu hätte es nicht ein professor gehrke
gebraucht jetzt die direkte persönliche
frage an sie wir haben eben während sie
noch in der pressekonferenz waren haben
wir darüber gesprochen und mein kollege
jürgen sagt er will natürlich auf jeden
fall nach köln eilen wenn die
möglichkeit besteht einsicht auch in das
erste in das erstes mehr hh
aber dann müssen wir noch mal schauen
erst mal dass der knopf im ohr
funktioniert hören sie mich herr bauer
hören sie mich noch sonst wäre das
natürlich schade wenn wir keine frage
mehr stellen können
herr bauer nicken sie einmal noch mal
ganz kurz sonst frage ich einfach
nochmal jürgen wir versuchen die leitung
aber nochmal herzustellen
und kommen auf patrick bauer noch mal
wenn das mit dem ton klappt und er uns
auch hören kann
sonst besteht er die frage nicht
zusammengebrochen
ja sagt der kölner so ist etwa immer jot
jejange aber was soll der quatsch wenn
die leitung die ich da ist für versuchen
ist einfach noch mal denn es wäre schön
mit patrick bauer auf dem wir jetzt
lange gewartet haben natürlich noch
weiter zu sprechen denn man merkt ja
schon da geht eine ganze menge in
jemanden vor der betroffener ist und das
ist ein wort was ich eigentlich ungern
sagen möchte weil da so viel drin steckt
wir haben über eine stunde telefoniert
und er hat mir beschrieben wie es ihm
geht
das kann man alles gar nicht erzählen
aber es ist es läuft einfach den rücken
runter wenn man erfährt wie heute noch
er ist 51 man muss sich vorstellen wie
lange das her ist dass er schüler in
einem internat war in einem jesuiten
orden und da mehrfach missbraucht worden
ist dass das konsequenzen für seine
familie heute hat das hat er mir
beschrieben dass er als vater wenn ich
richtig erinnerung habe von zwei kindern
völlig ausgefallen ist mit depressionen
und für seine kinder nicht da sein
konnte weil er halt immer noch drunter
leidet das muss man sich vor augen
halten kein kavaliersdelikt nichts und
eine tat die menschen so hat patrick
patrick bauer mir das beschrieben eben
lange bewegt und der andere sprecher das
hat er mir auch erzählt der des
betroffenen beirats hauke der auch als
protest wegen verschiedenen dingen
zurückgetreten ist von diesem amt als
sprecher hat ja auch geschrieben dass er
suizidgedanken hatte
das muss man sich immer noch mal vor
augen glaube ich halten wenn wir hier
über verantwortlichkeiten etc sprechen
jetzt haben wir eine frage die wir hier
bekommen hat michelle stefan fragt warum
werden nur priester erwähnt was ist denn
mit den nonnen die jahrzehnte mädchen in
den heimen missbraucht haben ich bin 73
jahre
es verfolgt mich mein ganzes leben ich
habs gerade erzählt was patrick baum mir
gesagt hat damit man versteht was
michael stephan sagt wenn sie sagt dass
verfolgt nicht mein ganzes leben
ich glaube das ist
man muss man jetzt dahingehend einordnen
das in diesem fall jetzt von bei dieser
studie das nicht nicht im fokus war das
ist eben ein punkt den wir vorhin schon
besprochen haben wenn es jetzt darum
geht eine umfassende aufarbeitung im
erzbistum köln oder auch in anderen
bistümern zu haben
dann würden auch ordensgemeinschaften
mit in den blick kommen in dem fall ging
es jetzt um die priester um die
hauptamtlichen mitarbeiter sozusagen in
der verein im verantwortungsbereich des
erzbistums köln
wir haben vor wenigen wochen ja zb
gehört aus dem bistum speyer wo auch ein
kinderheim das von ordensfrauen geführt
wurde wieder neu in den focus kam und
den umgang dort auch der ordensfrauen
mit den schutzbefohlenen der und das ist
eben so ein bisschen das problem auch
dieses flickenteppichs der verschiedenen
gutachten
jede organisation wir haben einerseits
die bistümer wir haben die
bischofskonferenz wir haben die orden
eigenständig jeder orden dann gibt es
die ordensoberen konferenz die auch
versucht die orden zu koordinieren da
gibt es dann sehr schmal orden die haben
viele viel personal und auch sag ich mal
ordentlich geld die können den gutachten
machen
oft sind solche taten aber wenn es um
kinderheime geht von von
ordensgemeinschaften stehen die in
verbindung die vielleicht zum teil heute
gar nicht mehr existieren oder wo es
heute noch irgendwie zehn oder zwölf
ordensfrauen gibt die jetzt selber gar
nicht die möglichkeiten haben personell
und finanziell eine aufarbeitung in
auftrag zu geben
da versucht dann die bischofskonferenz
auch zu unterstützen also da sind viele
viele dinge wir haben es vorhin ein
bisschen mit diesem föderalen system
verglichen
das macht es so schwierig und das macht
es für ganz viele betroffene dann auch
sehr frustrierend und und noch mal
wieder neu verletzend weil sie unter
umständen dann in einer einrichtung
betroffen sind die jetzt zum beispiel in
diesem kölner gutachten nicht
berücksichtigt sind oder die in einem
bestimmten gutachten eines bistums keine
berücksichtigung finden und die dann
sorge haben oder dann auch vielleicht
auch wirklich durch ein raster fallen
und am ende dann alleine da stehen dafür
hat man versucht zentrale an
auf stellen zu schaffen also jede
betroffene egal ob es jetzt einen orden
war oder nicht kann sich bei bei
unabhängigen beauftragten in den
bistümern melden oder bei der
bischofskonferenz
um da auch abhilfe zu schaffen jetzt
steht zum glück wieder die leitung nach
köln das heißt er kann uns wieder hören
patrick bauer
da ist er wieder so wir hören
vogelgezwitscher von der domplatte in
köln nicht wieder hören das ist
wunderbar ich wollte sie fragen
jürgen hat es bereits gesagt er hat
natürlich allergrößtes interesse auch
den termin wahrzunehmen wenn die
möglichkeit besteht einerseits in dieses
neue gutachten zu schauen dass jürgen du
sagt es ist im internet dann eben auch
hochgeladen wird aber bei dem termin ist
die chance dann eben auch dass mit dem
ersten gutachten zu vergleichen werden
sie diese chance irgendwie auch nutzen
am brennen sie jetzt auch darauf dass zu
vergleichen und zu wissen warum denn
dieses erste gutachten so lange
zurückgehalten worden ist ja natürlich
ich habe schon einen termin ich werde am
oder am 26 eine einsicht verschaffen
wobei auch das nur voraussichtlich oder
über oberflächlich sein kann weil ich
anderthalb stunden zeit haben wir 600
seiten anzugucken
da muss man mal gucken was sich dann in
der zeit überhaupt lesen kann
ja man muss ja sagen sogar 800 wir sind
ja überrascht wieviel getippt und
geschrieben worden ist professor gerke
hat es heute gesagt es ist ein baustein
es ist nicht das letzte
wie soll man sagen die spitze des turms
der letzte schlussstein eines großen
gebäudes das sich aufklärung nennen
sondern es ist nur ein kleiner stein
dieses gutachten sehen sie das auch so
was erwarten sie
was sich jetzt alles noch tun muss vor
allen dingen wenn man das resümee des
professors des juristen sieht der von
einem system von einer systembedingten
vertuschung spricht
ja also natürlich kann das jetzt nur der
anfang sein was ich eben schon gesagt
habe es fehlt tatsächlich die ethische
moralische bewertung und die muss jetzt
geschehen es muss aufgearbeitet werden
wer auch in der mittleren ebene dazu
beigetragen hat wir haben gehört dass da
nahmen in der untersuchung nicht genannt
worden sind
von einem personalchef der den
verfehlungen vorgeworfen werden von
einer justiziarin die namentlich nicht
genannt worden ist und da müssen wir
einfach gucken wie gehen wir damit um
wie gehen wir mit den dingen um die gelb
markiert waren an verfehlungen
pflichtverletzungen
das ist alles so ein kuddelmuddel im
moment und wir müssen jetzt abheben von
der aktenlage von den harten fakten die
wir haben auch hin zu den weichen fakten
und gucken was ist da wie so schien
jemand immer sagte in der dna der kirche
eigentlich falsch und dass so etwas
geschehen konnte uns daran müssen wir
jetzt arbeiten wir kriegen zuschriften
auch was sie angeht das möchte ich
unbedingt an sie in köln vor dem dom
weiterleiten
melanie rombach schreibt über facebook
ich bewundere herrn bauer dass er so
offen und klar damit umgeht und
christine lang schreibt klar sehr gute
klare forderungen von ihnen herrn bauer
also ein kompliment an sie und ich denke
sie haben es gerade selber gesagt da ist
rot über das haben wir jetzt gesprochen
es aber auch noch sehr viel geld und wir
wissen alle zusammen nicht was noch
weiterkommt jürgen und sie werden mit
sicherheit diese 800 seiten lesen auch
vergleichen mit dem ersten gutachten und
wir werden auch weiterhin verfolgen
natürlich gemeinsam was kardinal woelki
dann bei der nächsten pressekonferenz
sagen wird ob es weitere konsequenzen
aus rom gibt das ist sozusagen nur der
anfang wir haben es gesagt ein kleiner
stein im großen kölner dom was das thema
aufklärung angeht insofern denke ich
oder es wäre schön wenn wir uns wieder
sprechen dann mit weiteren neuen
erkenntnissen und für den jetzigen
zeitpunkt erst mal vielen dank herr
bauer nach köln vielen dank und bis bald
ja und an dieser stelle auch an
juristisch und an dieser stelle auch die
jürgen vielen vielen dank aber du hast
es auch deutlich gemacht das ist der
anfang wir werden mit sicherheit darüber
sprechen und wir sind alle gespannt was
du dann auch lesen wirst und an weiteren
erkenntnissen uns mitbringen was dir
vielen vielen dank
und an sie natürlich auch ein herzliches
dankeschön für ihr interesse dass wir
gemeinsam diese pressekonferenz verfolgt
haben zu dem neuen dem zweiten gutachten
unter statement von kardinal werke
vielen dank und einen schönen tag noch